Hey, listener, it's Stefan. I'm here a little early from my episode. I think we're probably waiting for Jason to clean his golf shoes and get his equipment going, which is very They go off community, but nevertheless I'm here. This is smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness.
嘿，听众朋友们，我是斯特凡。我比平时早了一点开始我的节目。我想我们大概在等杰森清理他的高尔夫球鞋并收拾他的装备，这非常符合他的风格，但不管怎样，我还是来了。这就是 SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness.
SmartLess。Smartless。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess。
Smartness. Smartness. Listener, we had a record earlier this morning. Went very well, very fun. Nice. We had we had a today's a two for and we had a what a three hour break, something like that. Yeah, what you guys do. Well, took a nap. Well, did you really? I did take a nap. I did too. No, I took a little nap, not too long.
SmartLess。Smartless。听众朋友们，今天一大早我们录过一期。进展非常顺利，也很有趣。不错。我们今天录了双份，中间有大概三个小时的休息时间，差不多吧。对，你们都干嘛去了。嗯，小睡了一会儿。真的吗？我确实小睡了一会儿。我也是。不，我眯了一会儿，没睡太久。
I watched obviously. No way. It took a little nap not too long. I watched obviously some some soccer stars and I'll get their first loss, huh? I did watch Arsenal get their first loss. So this dating this podcast, but I did watch that that match. It was very controversial. Was it? Yeah, there's a very controversial goal because they lost one meal and there was controversial goal. People are really mad at the the VAR, the video system referee. We don't need to put the audience into their own nap going over this. Sean, what'd you do? I did, I took a, I took a little nap. Just lunch before you nap.
我显然看了。不会吧。眯了一会儿，没睡太久。我显然看了一些足球比赛，阿森纳遭遇了他们的第一场失利，对吧？我确实看了阿森纳遭遇他们的第一场失利。所以这期播客是有时效性的，但我确实看了那场比赛。非常有争议。是吗？对，有一个非常有争议的进球，因为他们零比一输了，而且那个进球很有争议。大家对 VAR，也就是视频助理裁判系统真的很生气。我们没必要让听众为了讨论这个而自己去睡着。肖恩，你干嘛去了？我，我小睡了一会儿。你午睡前吃了午餐吗。
I had a BLT. You did? Yeah. And a BLT with extra mail. Your food is always so special. You ever just have like normal shit? What's not normal about a BLT? You have to make the bacon and put it on the side. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no Hey, can I guess what kind of bread it was on? White bread. White bread.
我吃了 BLT（培根生菜番茄三明治）。是吗？对。而且是一个加了特多蛋黄酱的 BLT。你的食物总是这么特别。你有没有吃过哪怕一次正常的垃圾食品？BLT 有什么不正常的？你得把培根做好然后放在旁边。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，听着，我能猜到是什么面包吗？白面包。白面包。
Country white. Will have you ever bought a loaf of white bread? I've always been the country of that. Sounds better. Will have you ever bought a loaf of white bread? Sure. Really? Have you ever, what is it?
乡村白面包。威尔，你买过一条白面包吗？我一直都买那种乡村面包。听起来更好。威尔，你买过一条白面包吗？当然买过。真的吗？你买过吗，那是神马？
But a loaf of white bread. Of course, what are you talking about? I don't know if I have, you have of course have. And I will say that the little kids, the little kids, they like white bread, but not, you know, they get a sort of, I don't know. It's children's food. That's all Sean eats. I eat white bread and drink milk almost every day.
买过一条白面包。废话，你在说什么呢？我不知道我有没有买过，你当然买过。而且我要说，小孩子，小孩子他们喜欢白面包，但不是那种，你知道的，他们会吃那种，我不知道。那是小孩子的食物。肖恩就只吃那个。我几乎每天都吃白面包喝牛奶。
What did you guys have? Jason, you and Amanda went over for dinner the other night. What did we have? What a beautiful, lovely dinner. Beautiful roasted chicken and roasted vegetables and a salad and then we had to hear about it the whole time. Scott and Sean were fucking furious. That's what they had to eat because we were there.
你们都吃了什么？杰森，前几天你和阿曼达去吃晚饭了。我们吃了什么？多么美妙、可爱的晚餐。美味的烤鸡、烤蔬菜、沙拉，然后我们一整晚都在听你们念叨这个。斯科特和肖恩气得要死。因为我们在那儿，他们只能吃那些。
No, we knew you were coming over. So we made sure there was like, you know, Jason and Amanda food. And then for dessert, there is there is brownies. This is Jason Amanda versus Sean and Scotty. We had the brownies. They had chocolate covered dates. So listen, true. That's true. Well, first of all, you supplied them. Think I'm, we would enjoy them. And, but you didn't touch the brownie. Oh, I sure did. Touched it big. You did my mouth touched it. I will. I've seen Jay, you know, sometimes I can have it big. You did? My mouth touched it. I will.
不，我们知道你要来。所以我们确保有那种，你知道的，杰森和阿曼达吃的食物。然后作为甜点，有布朗尼。这是杰森和阿曼达对阵肖恩和斯科蒂。我们吃了布朗尼。他们吃的是裹着巧克力的椰枣。所以听着，没错。那是真的。首先，是你提供的。以为我们会喜欢。而且，你根本没碰那个布朗尼。哦，我当然碰了。狠狠地碰了。你碰了，我的嘴碰到了。我会的。我见过杰，你知道的，有时候我可以吃。周日晚上，总会有人带，通常是你和斯科蒂还有别的什么人会带一份甜点。我见过杰森反复地，反复地分享。我有上瘾的问题，你知道的，但是，但是，但是，但是，嗯，伊莱今天问我关于晚餐的事，我不知道。不管怎样，我说，他问我杰森，你，哦，我们在谈论亚特兰大。嗯哼。
I've seen Jay, you know, sometimes I can have Sunday night, somebody will bring a, usually you and Scotty and somebody else will bring a dessert. And I've seen Jason over, over, over shared. I have addiction issues, you know, but, but, but, but, um, Eli was asking me today about dinner and I don't know. Anyway, I said, he asked me Jason, what you, oh, we were talking about Atlanta. Uh-huh.
我说他在那座我们最后住的那栋大楼里生活时都点什么外卖？我说，没有。不，我七点半就睡了。他大概七点半，会吃一点沙拉和一些苏打饼干。嗯，晚餐，是的。千真万确。
And I was saying he's like, well, what did he order in a lot when he was living up there in that building where we ended up? I said, no. No, I'm sleep by 7.30. He hold by 7.30, he'll have a little salad and some crackers. Well, dinner, yeah. True story.
真的吗？我说，这身体可不是开玩笑的。就这身板，可不是随随便便就能练出来的。不过昨晚吃晚饭时，杰森，昨晚吃晚饭时，我们在一家餐厅。我点了一份麦卡锡沙拉，不要培根，酱汁要另外装。酱汁要另外装，然后还有别的什么，不要鸡蛋什么的。不，不，不。别他妈的把它拌在一起，就把酱汁给我。
Really? I said, the body is no fluke. This body right here, it doesn't just have it. But last night at dinner, Jason, last night at dinner, we were at a restaurant. I have a McCarthy salad, no bacon, sauce, dressing on the side. Dressing on the side, and then something else, no egg or something. Nope, nope. Just don't fucking mix it and give me the dressing.
你那份沙拉点的是哪种酱？我熟悉那个地方。你会怎么做？对，就是那种精准混合的晚餐。对，就是那个。对。对，挺好的。真的挺好的。对，你可不想沙拉里倒太多酱，你知道的，那样会毁了所有的蔬菜。所以我不，我不喜欢喝沙拉酱，对。对。我才不信呢。好吧。那，那，那，现在你想聊聊一个懂得照顾自己的人。说到照顾自己这方面。
Which dressing did you ask for for that? I know the place. What would you do? Yeah, it's just just a bullseye mixed dinner grid. Yeah, the thing. Yeah. Yeah, it's nice. It's real nice. Yeah, you don't want a heavy pour on the salad, you know, it just ruins all the vegetables. So I don't, I don't like a drinking salad dressing, yeah. Yeah. I don't think so doubt it. All right. Let's, let's, let's, now you want to talk about somebody who knows what to do with themselves. When it comes to taking care of themselves.
对，我确实知道。我给你请了个嘉宾。等一下。我把笔记调出来。有这个，还有那个。我们来了。准备好了吗？安静。
Yeah, I do. I got a guest for you. Hold on. I pull up my notes here. There's that and here's this. Here we come. Ready? Quiet.
今天我们请到了一位在个人成就和团队合作方面同样出色的人物。他既富有又热心慈善。他既家喻户晓又温文尔雅。这个人是NBA历史上第一位全票当选的常规赛MVP。他9次入选NBA全明星。他拥有4个NBA总冠军，并且他是NBA总决赛中第一个命中103个三分球的球员。他被广泛认为NBA历史上最伟大的射手。他打高尔夫球也不赖，他就是我们今天的嘉宾，向斯蒂芬·库里打个招呼。快，斯蒂芬。对，前面。你好，先生。门。
Today we have someone who is equally successful in personal accomplishments as he is in teamwork. He is as rich as he is philanthropic. He is as famous as he is soft spoken. This man was the first to have been voted MVP unanimously in NBA history. He has nine NBA All-Star selections. He has four NBA championships, and he was the first player to hit 103 pointers in the NBA Finals. He is widely regarded as the greatest shooter in NBA history. He's not a bad golfer either, and he's our guest today, saying hello to Steph Curry. Shut, Steph. Yeah, front. Hello, sir. Door.
好吧。这是个博彩公司吗？这是侧门吗？关上后门？把它关掉。我简直不敢相信。是的。而且我娶了个加拿大人。
Okay. Is this a bookie? Is this a side door? Shut the back door? Shut it down. I can't believe this. Yes. And I'm married to Canadian.
是吗？我娶了个加拿大人。你花了很多时间在多伦多。是的，我是。是的，我是。欢迎我们这样做。欢迎我们这样做。斯蒂芬，我很高兴你今天能来。
Did you? I'm married to Canadian. And you spent a lot of time in Toronto. Yes, I do. Yes, I do. We're welcome to do. We're welcome to do. Steph, I'm very excited you're here today.
谢谢。很高兴能来到这里。很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你。肖恩，你不用假装。我待会儿自己会收拾。我们来聊聊这个。这更深奥。
Thank you. So this is great, great to be here. Great to meet you. Yeah, really nice to meet you. Sean, you don't have to fake it. I didn't do it to myself later. Let's talk about that. It goes deeper.
那种共鸣。我当然知道你是谁。我对你和你的生活印象深刻。是的，这太不可思议了。现在，我们把录制时间定在三点钟，是因为你今天早上必须去打高尔夫球吗？但愿如此。所以我在夏天度过了一个非常棒的高尔夫赛季。我想我在湖边路过你那一带时看到过你。但到了十月份我们开始赛季时，高尔夫球杆很快就会长满蜘蛛网。你根本不把它们带在身边吗？
The resonant. I am, of course, no, who you are. I'm very impressed with you in your life. Yeah, it's incredible. Now, are we recording this at three o'clock because you had to play golf this morning? I wish. So I had a really great golf season, I guess, in the summer. I think I saw you during the lakes passing by your neck of the woods. But come October when we start our season, the golf clubs develop some develops some cobbelabs pretty quick. You don't take them with you at all?
我尽量，如果运气好的话，我一个月大概打两次，但我们现在在美丽的俄亥俄州克利夫兰。我确信在四天三战之间。所以作为一个35岁、正值第15个赛季的人来说，大部分时间都用来保持尽可能好的状态。那么，对你来说，最关键的秘诀是什么？你，你，什么能让你，你尽量避免什么让你超级无敌累的事情？
I try to, I play maybe twice a month if I'm lucky, but we are in beautiful Cleveland, Ohio right now. I'm sure between three games and four nights. So as a 35 year old, am I 15th year? Most of the time is dedicated to staying as you feel as possible. Now, what's the big key on that for you? What do you, what, what, what gets you, what do you try to avoid that gets you super duper tired?
你，你，你用的是什么严重的手段？我刚才在笑。我刚才在说肖恩的午餐。我想，我要是能吃那个就好了。就是这样。对。对。我们很熟。肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，你的饼干袋。就是这样。对吧？对。我们很熟。
What do you, what do you, what do you use in white, serious? I was laughing. I was talking about Sean's lunch. I was like, I wish I could have had that. That's right. Right. Yeah. We know each other. Sean, Sean, Sean, Sean, Sean, your cookie that. That's right. Right? Yeah. We know each other.
肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，肖恩，你的饼干袋。这就是斯蒂芬极力想要避免的东西。就是那个饼干。这不就来了。但你知道吗，我敢打赌，等你到了53岁，等你到了53岁，你可能会吃一个。我可能会吃一个。对，所以小心点。有什么好期待的。
Sean, Sean, Sean, Sean, your cookie pouch. This is what Steph's trying to avoid. It's the cookie. There it is. But you know what, I bet when you're 53, when you're 53, you might have one. I might have one. Yeah, so watch out. Something to look forward to.
对。你爸爸退役后给自己买过饼干袋吗？买过，而且，呃，他在NBA打了16年。是吗？是的。他打了，呃，他打了，你知道的，86年被犹他克利夫兰选中，他在夏洛特度过了10年，我在那里长大，我的家人也在那里。
Yeah. Did your dad ever get himself a cookie pouch after he stopped playing? He did. And, uh, so he played 16 years in the NBA. He did? He did. He played, uh, he played, you know, drafted in 86 by Utah Cleveland and he spent 10 years in Charlotte, which is where I grew up, my family.
然后他的最后三年在多伦多度过，也就是，我在那里住了三年。我等不及要问那个显而易见的问题了。好吧，我问了。这意味这是你想去的还是强加给你的？也就是我在那里住了三年。我等不及要问那个显而易见的问题了。好吧，我问了。这意味这是你想去的还是强加给你的？两者都有点吧。
And then he ended up his last three years in Toronto, which is, uh, I lived there for three years. I can't wait for my obvious question. Just, yeah, I did it. Does that mean you wanted to do it or was it forced upon you? which is I lived there for three years. I can't wait for my obvious question. Yeah, I did it. Does that mean you wanted to do it or was it forced upon you? It was a little bit of both.
有点像是被动接受的，因为你周围全都是那个。你一直都在体育馆里。你跟着他，然后你对它产生了一种热爱。但我从小到大玩过所有运动，棒球、美式足球，当然还有高尔夫。所以你很热爱它。
It's kind of forced upon you just by, that's all you're in. You're in a gym all the time. You're following him and it's, you develop a love for it. But I played all the sports growing up, baseball, football, obviously golf too. But so you loved it.
你热爱体育。我很热爱。是的。而且我得以见证了他职业生涯的大部分时间，这很酷。因为我出生在他进入联盟的第三年。所以他在我12岁时退役了。抱歉，我在多伦多时我13岁。但当他退役后，锻炼绝对不是
You loved sports. I loved it. Yeah. And I got to see most of his career, which was cool. Because I was born his third year in the league. And so he retired when I was 12. And sorry, when I was 13 when I was in Toronto. But when he retired, he definitely working out was not
一段时间内的首要任务。然后当他，他受到启发是在，实际上，当我2011年结婚时，那是他恢复身材的契机。他不想走红毯时，对，我们甚至把那个抛到另一边去了。但你知道的，你知道的，
a priority for a while. And then when I, he got, he got an inspire when, actually, when I got married back in 2011, that was the, that was the emphasis for him to get back in shape. He didn't want to walk down the aisle with, right, we even went the footer to the other side. But you know, it's, you know,
这是，让我问你这个，如果一个人只靠沙拉和坚果，能在NBA坚持多久？你知道直说吧？哦，我会说那家伙，我通常是场上最矮的家伙。我要是在低位能把那个家伙挤退。如果他是个只吃沙拉和坚果的人，那很难找到他。确实。
it's, it's, let me ask you this, how long would a guy last in the NBA for all the eight was salad and nuts? You know what straight up? Oh, I'd say that guy, I'm the smallest guy usually out there. I'd be able to back that guy down in the post. If he was a Saladin nut, that's a hard time finding him. Exactly.
联盟中现在有没有盛行纯素生活方式？真的吗？真的吗？真的。老实说，我碰都不碰。我不知道他们是怎么摄入热量的。联盟中现在有没有盛行纯素生活方式？真的吗？真的吗？真的。老实说，我碰都不碰。我不知道他们是怎么摄入热量的。我知道这背后有科学依据，但我现在的队友克里斯·保罗，他吃纯素大约四年了。是的，我只是对他在飞机上或用餐时带的东西感到着迷，你知道的，什么，他是怎么获得营养的。我简直惊呆了。我只是盯着他看。我觉得自己像个尴尬的，你知道的，社交白痴。我只是盯着你说的每样东西，问一些问题，比如，怎么，怎么。
Is there the vegan lifestyle that's taken over the league? Really? Really? Yeah. Honestly, I don't touch it. I don't know how they get their calories in. Is there the vegan lifestyle is taking over the league really really really yeah I honestly I don't touch it. I don't know how they get their their calories in I know there's a science behind it, but one of my teammates Chris Paul now who's Been thinking vegan for about four years. Yeah, I just I'm fascinated by what he brings on the plane or at meal time You know what what what, how it gets his nourishment. I'm just amazed. I just stare at him. I feel like I'm an awkward like, you know, a social bad. I'm just staring at everything you say, asking questions like, how, how.
现在你，你提到了你从小到大玩过的所有那些运动。有没有哪项运动是你，你很不擅长的？就超级烂的那种？呃，我曾经拿过一次长曲棍球棍，天生就挺有这方面的天赋。别的真的就足球吧，你可以说我完全没有这方面的基因，但我运动神经好，所以我觉得我还能应付过去。你可以装装样子。篮球和足球在跑动上有很多相似之处，而且有很多
Now you, you mentioned all those sports that you played growing. Are there any sports that you're, that you're not great at? Like just terrible at? Uh, I've picked up a lacrosse stick once and just had a good neck for figuring out how to do that. Anything really soccer, I guess you could say I don't have any of these last year going on, but I'm athletic so I could get by, I think. You could fake it. There's a lot of similarities to basketball and soccer with the movement and it's a lot
网球般的步伐。你的网球水平怎么样？网球还算扎实。在变得更强。对，酷。你看？来吧。你的网球水平怎么样？网球还算扎实。在变得更强。对，酷。你看？来吧。
of tennis ball movement. How's your tennis game? Tennis to solid. It's getting stronger. Yeah, cool. See? Come on. How's your tennis game? It's tennis a solid. It's getting stronger. Yeah, cool. See? Come on.
你知道吗，阿什利，我们不久前刚请我们的好朋友约翰·麦肯纳来上播客。我们谈到了孩子们还小的时候的这种理念。他当时，他非常主张，孩子们不应该只玩一项运动。他说，你应该玩多项运动。这真的很重要。听起来你就是这么做的。我绝对推荐这个。有那么多，你知道的，互补的技能组合，以及，你知道的，
You know what, Ashley, we just had, we had our buddy, John McNeer on the podcast not long ago. And we talked about the idea of kids when they're young. He was, he's such a big proponent of, kids should not just play one sport. He's like, you should play multiple sports. That's really important. And it sounds like you did that. I prescribed that for sure. There's so many, you know, cross-over skill sets and, you know,
你与之互动的个性，对你的身体、思维的要求，特别是对那些接触到的较年轻的孩子来说。能够弄清楚什么对你来说是天生就会的，什么不是，以及你如何缩小这种差距。所以，是的，我直到13岁才把篮球当作我唯一的运动。即便如此，我业余时间还在打高尔夫球，并且还有其他一些好奇心。但也就是在那时，我才开始全神贯注。哇。太酷了。我在高中之前以及在小学时打过篮球。我需要一些视频片段。我得说。我不认为你谈到了小学的区别。我需要一些视频片段。我得说。是的，我不。我不认为。我不认为你谈到了其中的区别。
personalities that you interact with, the demands on your body, your mind, especially for , you know, younger kids that kind of get exposed. To be able to figure out like what comes naturally, what doesn't and how can you kind of close that gap. So yeah, I didn't pick basketball till I was 13 as my only sport. And even then I was still playing golf on the side and had some other curiosity. But that was when it came solely focused. Wow. That's cool. I played basketball and before high school and you in great school. I need some footage. I need to say. I don't think you talk about the difference for grade school. I need some footage. I need to say. Yeah, I don't. I don't think. I don't think you talk about the difference for it.
这些经历，我需要一些视频片段。我会弄一些视频片段的。我记得教练说，把球传给海斯，因为我从来拿不到球。还有把球传给海斯。他当时在喊，把球传给海斯。然后我会从所有队友身边跑开。只给我一次投篮机会，就像每10场比赛一次那样。
The experiences, I need some footage. I will do some footage. I remember the coach saying, give it to Hayes because I never got the ball. And give it to Hayes. He was screaming, give it to Hayes. And I would run down all the teammates with separate. Just give me one shot, like every 10 games.
太少了。你肯定拿过参与奖。只给我一次投篮机会，就像每10场比赛一次那样。太少了。你肯定拿过参与奖。就像，就像，就像，你可以去看他们怎么弄那个，他们拿到毛巾然后把它带进来，让他们。嗯，所以这是真的。嘿，斯蒂芬，刚开始打篮球时，有没有什么重大的挑战？
Aless. I'm just waiting. You got to participate in trophy for sure. just give me one shot like every 10 games. The less. You got a participation trophy for sure. It's like, it's like, it's like, you can go see where they do that, where they get like the towel get it and they bring it in and they let them. Um, so it's true. Hey, so Steph, was there any any significant challenges right at the beginning
大概没有吧？我的意思是，你很早就学会了，掌握你的投篮技巧。我确信你爸爸帮了你很多。有什么关于身高的吗？你可不小。你一直在长高。你最终身高长到多少？你有多高？你一直在长高。你最终身高长到多少？你有多高？我现在身高6英尺3英寸，但在我上高一的时候，我身高5英尺7英寸，体重约145磅。
to to playing basketball? Probably not, right? I mean, you learned early, get get your shooting technique. I'm sure your dad like helped you. Was there like your height? You weren't you weren't small. You were kept getting bigger. What do you what'd you top out at? How tall are you? kept getting bigger. What do you top out at? How tall are you? I'm six three right now, but I was five, seven, and about a hundred and forty,
哇。哇。有一张我和校队队友的照片，大家坐在最前面，盘着腿，就像，哇，真的。
five pounds my freshman year in high school. Wow. Wow. It was a picture of me and my varsity team like sitting up front, you know, cross-legged and just like, who, yeah. You could have,
就像我们刚才形容肖恩打篮球那样，如果你不知道我是谁，你看到那张照片，你会觉得，哦，那就是那个。所以随着你父亲开始让你进行体能训练，可能不会成功。如果你看看自己能长多高，但如果没有达到X高度，就开始考虑其他事情。
how we just described Sean playing basketball, you probably, if you didn't know who I was, you look at the picture, you're like, oh, that's that case. So then with your dad starting to condition you for like, it's probably not going to happen. If you will see how tall you get, but if you don't get to X, start thinking about other things.
是的，那就是，我是说，对于关于它是否是被迫的另一个问题。我是说，我很感激我父母引导我接触这项运动的方式，因为显然你有一个打过16年球的爸爸，对篮球以及这个未来有一种理解。但在早期我所拥有的身体素质、效率，你知道的，永远只有一种鼓励，那就是努力、摸索、在前进中建立信心，而不用太去想结果是什么。
Yeah, that was, I mean, to the other question about was a force. I mean, that was, I'm so grateful for how my parents approached introducing me to the game because obviously you have a dad at play 16 years, there's kind of an understanding of basketball as in this future. But the physicality, the efficiencies I had early, and you know, there was always just an encouragement to just work, figure it out, build confidence as you go without really thinking about what the results were.
就像，显然我知道什么是NBA。我知道什么是大学一级联盟篮球。我知道那是尝试获得好学校奖学金的好方法活。但他们教给我的一切以及我遇到的教练让我真正活在当下，这也是我现在试图教给孩子们的，因为有那么大的压力，你知道的，抛开运动不谈，
Like, obviously I knew what the NBA was. I knew what Division 1 basketball was. I knew that that was a good way to try to get a scholarship to a good school. But everything that they taught me and the coaches that I had kept me really in the moment, which is something I try to teach kids now, because there's such a pressure on, you know, sports aside,
不管你在说什么。有一种巨大的压力想要快进你到达那里的过程和旅程，因为每次你打开手机，展现在你面前的都是经过包装的完美成果。所以我在决赛中投进三分球，以及克服我职业生涯中遇到的所有逆境。
that doesn't matter what you're talking about. There's such a pressure to fast forward the process and the journey of how you get there because you see the polished product forced on you every time you open up your phone. And so me shooting, three's in the final and just go over coming all day adversity I had in my career.
这都只是那个快照。但如果你把时钟倒回，你去问我高二的时候，NBA是一个多么遥远的理念。我真的很享受打篮球和身处那样的环境。但真的是这样吗，考虑到你的血统，对吧？你父亲，我想你承担了所有额外的压力，如果我有幸进去了，
It's all just that snapshot. But if you rewind the clock back and you talk to me when I was a sophomore in high school, the NBA was such a distant idea. I was really enjoying playing basketball and being in that environment. But was it really, considering your lineage, right? Your father, I would imagine you had all the added pressure of, if I am lucky enough to get in,
我能打得那么好吗？而且，你是如何应对这一点的，因为你在那方面超额投入了？不仅如此，杰森，想想看。你有没有遇到过这种情况，你一定知道，你有着很好的手眼协调能力，你打过高尔夫，你玩过很多不同的运动，你知道自己很有运动天赋。
am I gonna be as good? And like, how did you deal with that because you over indexed there? But not only that Jason, think about this too. Did you have the thing where you had, you must have known, you had good hand-eye coordination, you played golf, you played a lot of different sports, you knew that you were athletic.
所以你心里一定有个底，觉得，嘿，如果我能把这些东西结合起来，如果我能把这架飞机平稳着陆，我要做一些超出压力的事情。但如果你这么做了，但如果你做不到，那对于你、对于他们来说就会很尴尬，比如，你是怎么应对这一切的？是的，我父母保持着很好的平衡。我想他们俩每天都在潜意识里体现了这一点。我爸爸打了16年球，我妈妈是我上小学时去的一所蒙台梭利学校的创始人。所以这有点像是一个很好的优先级平衡。
And so you you must have had an inkling that like, Hey, if I can bring this stuff together, if I can land this plane, I'm going to do some outside of the pressure. But if you do, but if you don't, there's that, that's going to be embarrassing for you for them for like, how did you deal with all that? Yeah, it is a nice balance in my parents. I guess inherently they both embodied it on the daily. My dad played 16 years, my mom was a founder of a Montesori school that I went to in elementary school. So it was kind of like a good balance of priorities.
如果我开始谈论诸如，我错过了第一场初中比赛因为我没有洗碗。他们让我做家务。这就像是一个写下来的，就像在我家里一样。所以伴随着优先级的严格要求，比如我来这里是为了确保你成绩优秀，确保你在课堂上照顾好自己，
If I start talking about like, I missed my first middle school game because I didn't do the dishes. They had my chores. This is like a written, it's like my house. So like the strictness that came with the priorities, like I was here to make sure you had good grades, make sure you took care of yourself in the classroom,
照顾好你的家庭和家里的事情。然后体育运动才是其次的。他们绝对不会在这上面打折扣。所以我认为这给了我们一种视角，你知道的，体育运动很有趣。这是我们家族的一部分。这是我们的血统。是的。但始终保持着客观的视角。
took care of your family and things at home. And then sports was down the way. They didn't let a slot on any of that. So I think it gave us a perspective of, you know, sports is fun. And this is something that is in our family. It's in our blood. Yeah. But there was always perspective.
但说到，是的，我知道我在某些领域很有天赋，但这其实与我从教练和招募人员那里得到的反馈并不相符，特别是当我上高中时，因为我在夏洛特长大。我爸爸在他16年的职业生涯里有10、11年都在那里度过。所以当你在夏洛特被称为库里的儿子时，人们都知道你是谁。所以确实有那种额外的压力。
But to the point of, yeah, I knew I was talented and gifted in certain areas, but it didn't really match up to the feedback I was getting from coaches and recruiters, especially when I got to high school, cause I grew up in Charlotte. My dad played 10, 11 of his 16 years there. So when you del Curry's son in Charlotte, like people know who you are. So there is that added pressure.
每当你走进体育馆，他们对你该成为什么样的人都有期望。但我其实不必，那不是家里的谈话内容，所以我可以从那种氛围中抽离出来，如果这说得通的话。很好，那里有一种很好的健康平衡。你当时在打球吗？你在学校打球吗，你显然在多伦多的学校上学或者在你的学校里？
Anytime you step foot in the gym, they have an expectation of who you're supposed to be. But I didn't really have to, that wasn't the conversation at home, so I kind of could get away from it, if that makes sense. It was nice, it was a nice healthy balance there. Were you playing, did you play at school, you obviously went to school in Toronto or in your school?
是的，奎斯维尔基督教学院，现在已经不存在了，但它在安大略省怡陶碧谷，哇。我知道怡陶碧谷，哇。好吧，你知道谁是怡陶碧谷人吗？是香尼·布兰纳汉，他是我们的朋友，他经营多伦多枫叶队，是节目的好朋友。我的朋友。我算是他的导师。这太棒了。这让我忍不住给他很多指导。他喋喋不休地谈论这个。太疯狂了。现在，斯蒂芬，你对这个有什么看法？你知道的，前几天我在看湖人的比赛，
Yeah, Queensway Christian College, it doesn't exist anymore, but it was in Atobaco, wow, Ontario, yeah. I know Atobaco, wow. All right, you know what's from Atobaco? Is is Shanny Brandon Shanahan who's a friend of ours who runs the Toronto Maple is good friend of the program. Friend of mine. I'm kind of a mentor to him. And that's great. That's make I just give him a lot of guidance. He goes on and on about it. It's crazy. Now, Steph, what's your feeling on this? You know, I was at the Laker game the other night
你知道的，他们在那里的球迷和氛围以及音乐等方面做得很好。但我很高兴听到你的赞许。我意识到，好吧，我在说刻薄的话之前先说点好听的。他们，你知道的，每当湖人队带球推进到半场时，他们都会播放音乐。我开始想，嗯，我不知道湖人队是否对这个感到恼火。他们听到这个很分心。基本上他们就是在用音乐来为这个过程配乐。这是个新现象，对吧？
and you know, they do a great job there with them for the crowd and everything with the music and all that. But I'll be happy to hear that you approve. I realize, well, I'm saying something nice before I say something shitty. They're, you know, they got music going every single time the Lakers take the ball down the court. And I started thinking, well, I wonder if the Lakers are pissed off about this. They're hearing this distracting. It's basically they're scoring this movie, you know, with music. That's a new thing, isn't it?
以前是不是那种比较安静，然后如果发生什么好事才播放音乐？现在，亲爱的，这就是另一回事了。这是我们体验的一部分。我们听得到，但它并没有真正困扰或影响我们。科比·布莱恩特曾经说过，我想当年有过一次对话，他谈到他在夏天训练时。他曾经要求绝对安静，因为那是他想要灌输给
Didn't it used to be kind of like quiet and then they play music if something good happens? Now, honey, here's to other. This is part of our experience. We hear it, but it doesn't really bother effect us. Kobe Bryant used to say, I guess there was a conversation in yeah where he talked about him working out in the summer. He used to have a dead silent because that's what he wanted to impart on
主场球迷的那种感觉。那就像是他想要的绝对安静的感觉，并以那种方式进行训练。在流程方面我没有那么狂热，但当你身处球场上时，你会听到音乐、氛围、听到球迷向你欢呼，所有这些类型的杂音。有趣的是，我曾经历过一场独特的比赛，
like the home crowd. That was like the feeling he wanted a dead silence and here's something to work out that way. I'm not that maniacal in terms of like, you know, process, but when you're out there in the court, you hear the music, the atmosphere, you hear the fans cheering at you, all that type of stuff. The funny part is I've been a part of one unique game
在纽约，麦迪逊广场花园。我想那是2017年。他们尝试了那种老派的方法，就是没有现场播音员，没有场内音乐，没有任何氛围，只有球迷的噪音，就像回到了20世纪40、50年代或者什么的，是的，那是糟糕透顶的体验。真的，就像你只能听到鞋底摩擦的声音，
in New York, Madison Square Garden. I think it was 2017. They tried like the old school method where there was just there was no PA announcer there was no in arena music at all no atmosphere was just the crowd noise was like taking it back to the nineteen forty-fifth years whatever yeah it was the worst experience really like you just hear the shoes squeaking yeah people clear their voices and drop the cups and stuff.
人们清嗓子的声音和掉落杯子的声音之类的。他们在半场时就放弃了。他们说，这行不通。我们还是回到以前那样吧。太糟糕了。半场休息。不管怎样，我们，每个人都在抱怨。所以斯蒂芬，你知道在高尔夫运动中，有一种叫做挥杆意念的东西吗？我们就像脑子里有这样一个念头，它能让你的整个挥杆动作变得流畅，
They abandoned it at halftime. They said, this is not working. Let's go back to that. That's terrible. Halftime. Anyway, we, everybody was complaining. So Steph, you know how in golf, there's like, there's thing called swing thoughts, right? We have like this one thing you think about and it gets your whole swing all in a groove,
对吧？就像把右肘收进去，或者，你知道的，或者是右手手指放在某个地方，不管到底是什么。你有没有一个在投篮时一直对你有效的挥杆意念？比如你会去想篮筐后沿、篮筐前沿还是网窝底部，从而形成某种你可以信赖的、多年来对你一直有效的弧线？是的，我认为最棒的，它是一个意念
right? Like just like tuck the right elbow in or, you know or right finger on the shit, whatever the hell it is. Do you have a swing thought that has consistently worked for you in shooting the basketball? Like do you think back of the rim or front of the rim or bottom of the net that puts it in a certain arc that you can count on that has worked for you over the years? Yeah, I think the biggest, it's a thought
和一个感觉同时存在，但如果我保持平衡，这可以意味着很多不同的东西，我可以向右、向左、向前、向后移动，单脚、对，双脚，无论是什么，但会有一种平衡感，你知道的，无论我在体育馆里投过多少次篮，无论是哪种投篮，还是在脑海中想象比赛随着你的思维过程等展开，就像我能感觉到什么时候我保持平衡，什么时候我保持平衡，我觉得我就绝不会投丢。所以你不会去过度思考它。就像，不，你试着让它保持很简单。肌肉记忆和力学原理会接管一切。但我出手前唯一想的是，我能进入合适的平衡状态吗，然后从那以后。这是我从你身上非常清楚地注意到的事情，
and a feeling all at the same time, but if I'm in balance, and that can mean a lot of different things, I can be moving right, left, forward, backward, one foot, right, two feet, whatever it is, but there's a feeling of balance that, you know, no matter how many times I've been in the gym, shooting any type of shot or envision, you know,
这是你身上非常独特的一个品质，你无论做什么事情，似乎总是那么自在、优雅和冷静。是的，当需要的时候你是爆发力十足的，速度极快的。但在大多数情况下，我所感受到的是，你所做的一切都有一种冷静和自在，我敢打赌每个球员都希望自己能拥有。好吧，我补充一点。
a game kind of unfolding with your mental process and all that, like I can feel when I'm in balance and when I'm in balance, I feel like I'm never going to miss. And so you don't think too hard about it. Like, no, you try to keep it really simple. The muscle memory and mechanics take over. But all I'm thinking about right before I shoot is, can I get into proper balance and then from there? It is something I noticed so clearly about you,
我有过同样的感受，因为有时你在那么多不同的情况下观察你。显然你是一个竞争者，你看到有些人在某些情况下会非常激动，无论如何。你保持非常冷静。你似乎非常专注于当下。这是你有意在练习的吗？当然。他当时就是这么问的。问题是什么？源于快乐。这就是快乐的来源。所以其中有一种平静，但我场上就像个小孩子，
is such a unique quality of yours that you always seem to be so at ease and graceful and calm with everything that you do. Yes, you're explosive and you're fast when you need to. But for the most part, what I sort of take away is that there's just a calmness and an ease to everything that you do that I bet every player wish they had. Well, I'll add to that.
哪怕，你知道的，已经打了15年。如果我失去了这种感觉，那么我知道就是该退役的时候了，因为对当下发生的事情的觉知和正念，我真的完全沉浸在比赛中。所以，篮球的工作或商业属性有时会悄悄潜入，因为在组建球队的过程中有太多事情要处理，漫长的82场比赛赛程中的起起落落，或者每晚都要拿高水平表现的压力。但老实说，当我踏上球场的那一刻，只有纯粹的快乐。这就是我栖息的世界。我们马上回来。
I've had the same thing because sometimes you're watching you in so many different situations. And obviously you're a competitor and you see guys get some guys get really heated, whatever. You stay very calm. You seem very present in the moment. Is that something that you work on? Oh, for sure. That's what he was like. What's the question? Coming out of the joy. That's where the joy comes from. So there's a calmness to it, but I'm a little kid out there on the
感谢 Rocket Money 对本节目的支持。你知道超过80%的人我们马上回来。这就是 Rocket Money 存在的原因。Rocket Money 是一款个人理财应用程序，可以查找并取消你不想要的订阅。它能在一处监控你的支出并帮助你降低账单。使用 Rocket Money，只需按一下按钮，你就可以轻松取消那些你不想要的订阅。再也不用忍受漫长的等待时间或给客服发烦人的电子邮件了。Rocket Money 为你完成所有工作。Rocket Money 甚至可以帮你协商将账单降低多达 20%。你所需要做的就是拍下你的账单照片，剩下的交给 Rocket Money 处理。Rocket Money 还允许你在一个地方监控所有费用。
court even, you know, 15 years in. If I ever lose that, then I know it'll be time to quit because the presence and the mindfulness of what's happening right now and literally I get lost in the game. So the work or the business of basketball creeps in from time to time because there's so much that goes on in terms of putting the team together and the ups and downs of an 82 game schedule or the pressures of performing every single night. But honestly, when I step foot on the floor, it's just pure joy. And that's where I live. We'll be right back.
根据你过去的消费情况推荐定制预算，当你达到消费限额时，他们甚至会向你发送通知。凭借超过500万的用户，Rocket Money 已经帮助其客户平均每年节省720美元，迄今为止总共节省了10亿美元。不要再把钱浪费在你不使用的东西上了。访问 rocketmoney.com/smartless 取消你不想要的订阅并以简单的方式管理你的资金。这就是 rocketmoney.com/smartless。rocketmoney.com/smartless。
Thank you to Rocket Money for their support. Did you know over 80% of people We'll be right back. That's why Rocket Money is here. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions. Monitor's your spending and helps lower your bills all in one place. With Rocket Money, you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service. Rocket Money does all the work for you. Rocket Money can even negotiate to lower your bills for you by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and rocket money takes care of the rest. Rocket money also lets you monitor all your expenses in one place.
money.com/smartless rocketmoney.com/smartless。非常感谢我们在梅西百货的朋友赞助本期播客节目。从现在到 11 月 25 日星期六，梅西百货的在线黑色星期五活动为你大幅节省你一整年一直在等待抢购的生活必需品和礼品。从家电（你好，立式搅拌机）和厨具到寝具和自我护理必需品，你会在每个房间所需的精选商品中找到最划算的价格。
Recommends custom budgets based on your past spending and they'll even send you notifications when you've reached your spending limits. With over 5 million users in counting, rocket money has helped save its customers an average of $720 a year and $1 billion in total saving so far. Stop wasting money on things you don't use. Cancel your unwanted subscriptions and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless. Rocketmoney.com slash smartless.
此外，购买最新服装潮流、设计师手袋、珠宝和你最喜欢的美容品牌的特价商品。通过对手表和无线耳机等礼品的大幅优惠来削减你的礼品清单。别忘了超级好玩的玩具。舒适的冬季装备以及更多你生活中的孩子们会很高兴收到的独特发现。此外，消费满 25 美元即可享受免费配送。
at money.com slash smartless rocket money.com slash smartless. A big thank you to our friends at Macy's for sponsoring this episode of the pod cast. From now until Saturday, November 25, Macy's online Black Friday event is saving you big on the essentials and gifts you've been waiting to snatch up all year. From appliances, hello, stand mixer, and cookware to bedding and self-care staples, you'll find great prices for the picks you need in every room.
所以请在 11 月 25 日之前光临梅西百货实体店或访问 Macy's.com。这就是 11 月 25 日之前的 Macy's.com。这就是 Macy's.com。某些条件适用。请查看 Macy's.com 了解详情。SmartLess 由 ADT 赞助。现在，ADT 专业安装 Google Nest 产品，让你的家既安全又智能。
Plus, shop specials on the latest clothing trends, designer handbags, jewelry, and your fave beauty brands. And chip away your gift list with big savings on gifts like watches and wireless headphones. Don't forget super fun toys. Cozy Winter Gear and more unique finds that the kids in your life will be excited to get. Plus, get free shipping when you spend $25.
你可以从几乎任何地方查看你的家并管理你的安全系统。借助 Nest 摄像机和 Nest 门铃，你甚至可以获得智能警报，以便收到关于最重要事情的通知。Google Nest 摄像机可以区分人、动物、车辆，或者配合 Nest 门铃甚至可以区分包裹。我的天，伙计们，这科技，绝了！作为每月 ADT 服务的一部分，通过 Nest Aware，你可以获得 30 天的事件视频历史记录，甚至更智能的通知，例如当看到熟悉或陌生的面孔时。
So visit Macy's in store or check out Macy's.com before November 25th. That's Macy's.com before November 25th. That's Macy's.com. Some exclusions apply. Check out Macy's.com for details. SmartLess is sponsored by ADT. Now ADT professionally installs Google Nest products, so your home is safe and smart.
我喜欢这个。我想你也会喜欢它。此外，当每一秒都至关重要时，你可以信赖 ADT 的 7x24 小时专业监控。只需轻轻一按，即可查看警报事件的视频并验证或取消警报。当家庭安全领域最值得信赖的名字加上 Google 的智能技术时，你知道你得到了什么吗？你得到了一个没有后顾之忧的家。今天就访问 ADT.com 或致电 1-800-ADT-ASAP。Google、Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell 和 Nest Aware 是 Google LLC 的商标。好了，回到节目中。
You can check in on your home and manage your security system from virtually anywhere. With Nest Cam's and the Nest Doorbell, you can even get intelligent alerts so you receive notifications on what matters most. Google Nest Cam's can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nest Doorbell even a package. I mean, guys, technology, what? And with Nest aware, as part of your monthly ADT service, you get 30 days of event, video, history, and even smarter notifications like when a familiar or unfamiliar face is seen.
我有两个问题要问，请一个一个来。不，我是在等那个两部分的问题，因为我知道这会怎么发展。会是这样的。哦，对了。太糟糕了。因为要把它们引出来。
I like that. I think that you like it too. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name in home security adds the intelligence of Google, you know what you got? You got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP. Google, Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. All right, back to the show.
我得把这些问出来。你在球场上经历过的最糟糕的冲突是什么，最严重的伤病又是什么？哦，太棒了，太棒了。最糟糕的冲突。你在球场上经历过的最糟糕的冲突是什么，最严重的伤病又是什么？哦，太糟糕了，太糟糕了。最糟糕的冲突。不管怎样，我们被你狠狠修理过吗？不，是我挨过修理。是在，我想那是在YouTube上，2013年在印第安纳。
My two questions that I have to ask is, one of the time, please. No, I was waiting for the two-parter, because I know how this goes. It goes. Oh, yeah. The worst. Because the guy to get them in.
罗伊·希伯特，大卫·韦斯特。哦，对。我当时的队友大卫·李，罗伊·希伯特和大卫·李在冲向篮筐的路上杠上了。这就像是彪形大汉之间的犯罪。后卫和小个子球员都躲开。这在联盟里算是一个众所周知的常识了，
I gotta get these in. Worst fight you've ever had on the court and worst injury. Oh, great, great. Worst fight. Anyway ever had on the court and worst injury. Oh, great, great. Worst fight. Anyway, we're gotten a beat down from you? No, I've gotten a beat down. It was in, I think it's on YouTube, so it was in Indiana in 2013.
当大个子们动真格的时候。周围的一切都不重要了。我这个大笨蛋偏要凑过去，你知道的，去保护我的队友。所以他们杠上了，胸口撞胸口，我从后面跑去抓罗伊·希伯特。他身高7英尺，体重可能290到280磅。我试图从后面抓住他，把他从我队友身上拉开。我跟你说，那感觉就像，
Roy Hibbert, David West. Oh, yeah. And my teammate at the time, David Lee, Roy Hibbert and David Lee kind of squared up on the way at the basket. And it was like big man on big man crime. Guards and little guys stay out the way. Like that's kind of a known thing in the league
就像从苍蝇身上拍下一只苍蝇一样，他 literalmente（字面意思）随手用左手一挥，然后我就，那正是在篮筐底下。我直接飞到了底角，双脚离地落地，然后滑过整个球场。现在我很尴尬，我不得不站起来，装作我要卷土重来的样子。就在那时，大卫·韦斯特，他就像是球场上的超级惩罚者、护卫。
when the big guys are going at it. There's everything else around, doesn't matter. My dumbass wanted to get in there and, you know, protect my teammate. So they square up, they chest bump, and I run up behind Roy Hebert. He's seven foot, probably two hundred and ninety two and eighty pounds. And I try to grab him from the back and like pull him off my teammate. And when I tell you, it was like, swatting the fly off,
当大个子们在场上激烈冲突时，其他一切都不重要了。我这个笨蛋当时就想冲进去，你知道的，保护我的队友。他们面对面站着，胸口撞胸口，我从罗伊·希伯特背后冲了过去。他身高七尺，体重大概二百九两百八十磅。我试图从后面抱住他，把他从我队友身上拉开。我跟你说，那感觉就像是在赶走一只苍蝇一样。
he literally just took his left hand and just, and I went, it was literally under the basket. I flew all the way to the corner, like, feed off, land slid across the court. So now I'm embarrassed, I have to like get up and act like I'm coming back for more. And that's when David West, he was like the big punisher, the enforcer on the court.
他 literalmente 只是用左手那么一挥，当时我就在篮筐底下。我整个人飞到了底角，滑行着摔倒在场地上。这下我挺尴尬的，不得不站起来，装作还要继续较量的样子。就在那时，大卫·韦斯特——他在场上就像是个狠角色、执行者。
And he like kind of chest hit, you know, stiff arms me and pushing me to my place and like just holds me one hand. And it's all this commotion on him. And later the story is, I would have gone for it that he just held me back. Yeah, I was gonna go for you. He say by the way Roy Hibbert nice guy. Very guy. Got a mean look got a mean left left swimmer. He's got a mean. He's got left spot. He calls it. He's got a mean left. I never knew how strong will was until we were doing our, and I, I had no idea you were. I'm not taking my shirt off, dude. No, but he really, like, so.
然后他有点像胸口撞了我一下，你知道的，伸直手臂把我推到一边，单手就把我给拦住了。现场为了他闹得沸沸扬扬的。后来他们说，我要是真想跟他干，他也就只能把我拦下来。对啊，我是打算去帮你的。他顺便说了一句，罗伊·希伯特这人不错。人挺好。长了一张凶相的脸，左手还有一记厉害的左勾拳。他有一记厉害的。他有一记厉害的左手。他自己这么叫的。他有一记厉害的左手。我以前真不知道威尔力气这么大，直到我们在做那个，然后我，我完全不知道你是。我才不会把衬衫脱了呢，老兄。不，但他真的，就是，所以。
He's, it's so, he's so in assuming I tried to push him with all of my body weight. I couldn't push him an inch. Yeah, it's, it's annoying. All right. Yeah. I will ask you this. Do you, do you apply that same kind of approach and you talk about the balance and being present when you do all, all, other sportly like when you play golf or do you have because some people and I'm not going to name names
他，这太，他太低调了，我用全身的体重去推他，结果连一英寸都推不动。对，这，这挺烦人的。行吧。对。我想问你这个。你在做所有其他运动时，比如打高尔夫球的时候，或者当你有——因为有些人，我可不点名——
some people when they stand over the ball, they stand there like a psycho and they might be up to 30 seconds like a frickin psycho. Like you think this guy I'm glad he's over the ball because otherwise he's going to be out. You know, I check this is like much shorter now. It is. I heard you're working on it, right? I know.
有些人站在球后的时候，站在那里就像个神经病一样，可能会像个该死的神经病一样站上足足30秒。你会觉得这家伙——我真庆幸他在击球准备状态，不然他早就被罚出去了。你知道的，我看看这个现在短多了。确实短了。我听说你在努力改进，对吧？我知道。
He is working on his process. You've heard about the process. Yeah. So would you say, but do you, do you do that? Or do you just, you like just swing athletically and just do it? And the athletic tendencies take over. I am as maniacal about the game of golf Jason is just in terms of like I know there's always something to work on and get better and there's I'm creative in that mindset where you know
他在改进他的流程。你听说过那个流程吧。对。所以你会说，但是你，你会那样做吗？还是说，你只是像个运动员一样挥杆，直接去打？然后让运动本能接管？我对高尔夫球的痴迷程度和杰森差不多，我是指我知道总有地方需要改进，让自己变得更好，而且我在那种心态上很有创造力，你知道的
Every little detail kind of matters and I have to really try to turn all those thoughts off because they will get the best of you Especially I playing, I mean, selfishly been playing the best golf of my life and so it's like, how good can I really get? Yeah. This summer you run fire. You're a scratch, aren't you? I got to the other side of that. I'm like a plus two right now, which is, and how old do you, you're 35?
每一个小细节其实都很重要，我必须得努力把那些想法全都关掉，因为它们会击垮你，尤其是最近——我是说，自私点讲，我正在打出我人生中最好的高尔夫，所以我就在想，我到底能打得有多好？对啊。你今年状态火热。你现在是差点为零了吧？我甚至突破那个水平了。我现在大概是正二左右，这，那你今年多大，35岁？
35, okay, so you have 15 years before the Champions Tour if you want it. If you want it, so 15 more years of training, you could be unstoppable on the champions tour. If you want to do that at 50, right, you can make that decision. That is a goal for sure. I know there's a, in the golf world, there's a lot of, you know, the arts celebrity and pro-AM stuff. And so you can scratch the competitive itch here and there, especially when I get the nine months of my basketball season back when it's all said none.
35岁，好吧，如果你想的话，距离冠军巡回赛你还有15年时间。如果你想去的话，再有15年的训练，你在冠军巡回赛上绝对能势不可挡。如果你在50岁时想去的话，对吧，你可以做那个决定。那绝对是一个目标。我知道在高尔夫世界里，有很多那种，你知道的，演艺界名人和业余职业配对赛。所以你时不时可以满足一下自己对竞技的渴望，尤其是当我把长达九个月的篮球赛季结束后的时间空出来的时候。
But yeah, champions tour, I mean, I'm sick. Like basketball could be on, I might have that on my phone, but on TV, it's golf channel. It's just a problem. Yeah, you owe me both. My wife thinks I'm such an idiot. Well, you know that the other night, a lot of apologies. Jason was over and I showed him my golf channel, which was this old house on PBS. I still watch this old house.
但是，对，冠军巡回赛，我是说，我已经魔怔了。比如正播着篮球比赛，我可能还会用手机看一眼，但电视上播的肯定是高尔夫频道的节目。这简直是个问题。对，你俩都这样。我老婆觉得我简直是个白痴。好吧，你知道前天晚上，经过一番真诚的道歉，杰森来我家，我给他看了我的高尔夫频道，其实是PBS电视台的《老房子》。我到现在还在看《老房子》。
Do you know, you know that, Sean? I sure that. Oh, it's like, it's like from the 1970s, it's still on it. They do, they build homes, they build houses. Oh, yeah. Yeah, it's, it's, it's really, you know, who likes it? People are in commas. They play just to have so that they know that there's or people that just can't, they
你知道吗，你知道那个吗，肖恩？我当然知道了。哦，那节目，那是70年代的节目了，现在还在播。他们做的事，就是建造家园，他们建造房子。哦，对。对，真的，你知道谁喜欢看吗？那些喜欢安稳过日子的人。他们看这个只是为了确保有节目可看，或者是那些根本就
can't roll a TV into a room if something's going to come up and they can't find their remote control. Those are the further what love. Yeah. If the remote is broken, they're out of the room. Yeah. Oh, they're strapped to a chair and it's stuck on PBS. It's the best show that they'll have. I said Jason, a video this morning, Jason's game has gotten so good. In my days, I don't have it.'t have it been playing as much but he's not a plus, but your game's good. I sent him this video today of this dude who played 18 holes with a five iron this morning. And only one to do was break 80 and he shot what is shooting 76? He shot 78. Yeah, what with a five iron? Yeah, he plays on the, he plays on the DP tour at European guy.
没办法把电视推到房间里看，又找不到遥控器的人。那些才是真正的死忠粉。对。如果遥控器坏了，他们就只能呆在房间里出不去了。对啊。哦，他们被绑在椅子上，电视死死锁定在PBS上。那是他们能看到的最好的节目了。我今天早上给杰森发了个视频，杰森现在的球技变得太好了。在当年我可没这水平。我没这水平，没打那么多，但他的水平不低。我今天给他发了这个视频，视频里有个家伙今天早上只用一支5号铁杆打完了18洞。他唯一的目的就是成绩打破80杆，结果他打了多少？他打了76杆？他打了78杆。对，用一支5号铁杆？对，他是在DP巡回赛打球的欧洲选手。
He did. That tells you how good those guys are. Yeah, he's two bunk, he's hit two green side bunkers shots, flop shots with a five iron dude. Yeah, it was crazy. We'll send it to you. Talk to me about you and Clay Thompson, the splash brothers, how did you develop the chemistry with him?
他真的做到了。这说明那些家伙有多厉害。对啊，他有两个沙坑球，是在果岭边上的沙坑球，用5号铁杆打出的挑高球，老兄。对，太疯狂了。我们会发给你的。跟我聊聊你和克莱·汤普森吧，作为“水花兄弟”，你们俩的默契是怎么培养起来的？
Is that, is that, you know, when anyone's ever asked me about chemistry with an actor or something like that, that it, I always say, well, it's not something you wore. It's just, that person's just nice. It's just, it's easy. If someone's not a prick, you can get along with them and you have chemistry immediately. Is that as simple as it is with you with life? Yes, transfer what it is to our relationship for sure.
是不是，你知道的，每当有人问起我和某个演员的默契之类的问题时，我总是回答，这可不是靠强求得来的。只是因为那个人刚好很好相处。一切都很自然。只要对方不是个混蛋，你就能和他合得来，瞬间就能培养出默契。你和克莱之间也是这么简单吗？是的，我们俩的关系毫无疑问就是这样的。
Like we've been together on the court now for 12 years. And then you add Dreymon green to that for 11. So it's insane to think that two guys who've had dads that played in the NBA as well. That's what I was going to say. And like you said, have a good perspective about what we worked for to get here and you know, approach life very similarly with appreciation and gratitude that we kind of hit it off in the jump. And I don't know like when you get into these type of friendships and you know, from your standpoint with your, your people in the same profession,
就像我们在场上已经并肩作战12年了。然后德雷蒙德·格林也加入进来11年了。所以很难想象，有两个家伙，他们的父亲以前也都在NBA打过球。我正想这么说呢。而且就像你说的，我们对于为了来到这里付出了多少努力有着很好的心态，你知道的，对待生活有着非常相似的态度，充满了感激和感恩，所以我们一拍即合。我不知道，当你经历这种类型的友谊时——从你的角度来看，和你的那些同行们，
you know, comments, whatever actors that you kind of sharpen each other's skillsets just about being around each other. And that's how we've been this entire time. It's not something that we actually like really talk about. It's like, you know, we don't come in and sit down at dinner. I would pretend like you're trying to shoot this year. What's your elbow at 90 degrees? But it's more just than we're in that environment. Our work ethics are pretty, you know, top knives in terms of, you know,
你知道的，喜剧演员，或是各种演员——你们通过彼此陪伴，其实是在互相打磨各自的技能。我们一直以来就是这样的。这其实不是那种我们会拿出来正经讨论的事情。我们不会一坐到餐桌旁就假模假样地讨论：“你今年打算怎么投篮啊？你的手肘是不是保持在90度？”比起这个，更多的是因为我们身处那样的环境之中。我们的职业道德可以说是非常顶尖的，
being able to try to figure out how to get better every single year. And that iron sharpen's iron is real. And there's such a respect level for the way that he approaches basketball and life. And that's why we're still doing it. And I'll bet the two of you with that kind of harmony and kindness and quiet leadership and all that stuff, it's infectious in the team, correct? Like you guys, I bet, have created a culture over there that it should be no surprise that you guys have
都在努力想方设法让自己每年都变得更好。这种“铁杵磨成针”的道理是千真万确的。而且我们对彼此对待篮球和生活的方式有着极高的尊重。这就是为什么我们现在还在坚持打球。我敢说，你们两个带着这种和谐、善良、默默的领导力以及所有这些品质，对整个团队有着极大的感染力，对吧？我敢打赌，你们在那里建立了一种球队文化，所以你们能够
one that extra 10 to 15 games each year, whatever it takes to get to a place where you're in the finals. And once you're in the finals, that kind of harmony and a team environment really yields the extra thing that you need to be excellent as opposed to great. Yes? For sure. The culture part of a lot of different ways to lead, right?
每年多赢那10到15场比赛，无论需要付出什么最终打进总决赛，这根本一点也不让人意外。一旦你进了总决赛，球队氛围中的这种和谐，确实能转化成让你从“伟大”蜕变为“卓越”所额外需要的东西。对吗？肯定的。球队文化这部分……领导球队有很多不同的方式，对吧？
There's a lot of different ways. You can be the loud one that needs to say something about everything. You can be the lead by example type. You can be the ones that show up when the lights are brightest and galvanize that confidence within the team. But following Steve Kerr, our coach, and the legendary coaches that he played for Phil Jackson, Greg Popovich played alongside Michael Kerr.
有很多不同的方式。你可以做那个大嗓门，对任何事都要指手画脚的人。你可以做那种以身作则的模范。你也可以做那种在聚光灯最亮时挺身而出、凝聚全队信心的人。但是跟随史蒂夫·科尔——我们的教练，以及他曾效力过的那些传奇教练，比如菲尔·杰克逊、格雷格·波波维奇，他曾和迈克尔（·乔丹）并肩作战。
And it's been famously a really, really nice guy. Yeah. He's just a great manager of people, like an impersonable guy. He seems to have a very sort of similar disposition. Obviously, very different personality, but different disposition to Greg Popovich, both of whom I don't know at all. But it just seems like they have a very similar kind of vibe.
而且他出了名是个非常好的人。对。他非常善于管理人际关系，是个很平易近人的人。他似乎有一种和格雷格·波波维奇非常相似的性格倾向。当然，他们的个性非常不同，但面对事情的倾向却很相似，尽管这两个人我一点都不了解。但看起来他们有着非常相似的行事风格。
Is that right? Estrate shooters, they have a great sense kind of vibe. Is that right? It's straight shooters. They have a great sense of humor. Yeah. They have a perspective that our problems in the NBA and they're real. Like we're trying to win at the highest level. There's this pressure.
是这样吗？他们都是直言不讳的人，有着极好的幽默感。是这样吗？他们都是直言不讳的人，有着极好的幽默感。对。他们有一种清醒的认识，知道我们在NBA遇到的问题都是真实存在的。比如我们正试图在最高水平上赢球。这里面充满了压力。
This is a multi-billion dollar industry that is set up to test you in all different ways. And if you want to win at the highest level, it's going to demand a lot from you. set up to test you in all different ways. And if you want to win at the highest levels, it's gonna demand a lot from you. But, you know, he has a great way of kind of explaining, like, we're blessed, man, we get to play basketball for a living and he reminds us to that every single day
这是一个价值数十亿美元的行业，它会在方方面面考验你。如果你想在最高水平上取胜，它就会对你提出很高的要求。它会在方方面面考验你。如果你想在最高水平上取胜，它就会对你提出很高的要求。但是，你知道的，他有一种很好的方式来解释这一切，比如：“我们很幸运，伙计，我们能以打篮球为生。”他每天都在提醒我们这一点，
when we come in. And that kind of just levels of playing field. He's level of trust within each other. And he does the best job of, when you come into a team kind of element. I don't care if it's sports, it's whatever fast of the life. Everybody has a specific role to play and he makes sure that that's clear, but it doesn't diminish your value to the success of the group.
当我们走进球馆的时候。这种心态拉平了竞争环境。他对彼此充满了信任。而且当新成员加入一个团队时，他总是能把工作做到极致。我不管这是体育运动，还是生活的其他什么方面。每个人都有自己特定的角色要去扮演，他会确保这一点非常清晰，但这并不会削弱你对集体成功的价值。
I think he has a great way of managing that process of from day one to the end, making guys believe in that and that's why we've been able to sustain this level of success for a long time. But what do you guys do season to season? I've often wondered, like, you come in, you win a few championships, and so you're the best, you guys are the best, you've got an unbelievable team, you got great chemistry. What does it got like Steve Kerr say when you come in to camp whatever that is August, September to get ready for the new season? Do guys like him go, okay, well, we won last year, this year our approach is going to be because obviously the goal, like if he sat down and goes, we want to win a championship, like, yeah, no shit. Everyone's the one to win a championship. Does he, do they set different goals? They go, this is, this is what we're
我觉得他有一种很棒的方式来管理这个流程，从第一天到最后，让球员们始终坚信这一点，这就是为什么我们能够长期保持这种成功水平的原因。不过你们在赛季与赛季之间是怎么做的呢？我经常纳闷，比如，你们来到这里，赢得了几次总冠军，所以你们是最棒的，你们拥有不可思议的球队，你们有极好的默契。当你们在8月或9月无论什么时候来到训练营为新赛季做准备时，像史蒂夫·科尔这样的人会说些什么？像他这样的人会说：“好吧，我们去年赢了，今年我们的方法将是……”因为很显然，目标——如果他坐下来宣称“我们想赢得总冠军”，那大家都会觉得“废话，这还用说”。每个人都想赢得总冠军。难道他们会设定不同的目标吗？他们会说：“这就是我们
going to do this year. Our approach is going to be different. Like, yeah, there's a way. I talked about what's happening right now. Like we've won four championships since 2015. We've been in six finals. So we've lost two of them. We lost in the second round last year to the Lakers. On a down year for us, which is that's how the high standard we've set.
今年要做的事情。我们的方法会有所不同。”就像，是的，有这么一种方式。我来谈谈眼下的情况。比如自2015年以来我们已经赢得了四座总冠军。我们六次打进总决赛。所以我们输了两次。去年我们在第二轮输给了湖人队。对我们来说这是一个低谷期，但这就是我们设定的高标准。
Yeah, came into this year. And to your point,, obviously everybody knows if we don't win a championship, then it's a failed season for us because of the standard. Cool. You can't just come in and say that like there has to be a level of detail of how you're prosaier. For us, it's, we have to win the week. That's what we call it. So however many games there are that week, it gives you a singular focus on what do you need to do
是的，今年卷土重来。说到你的观点，显然每个人都知道如果我们没有赢得总冠军，那对我们而言就是一个失败的赛季，因为我们的标准就摆在那里。酷。你不能光是走进球馆这么说，必须要有具体的细节，关于你的过程要怎么做。对我们来说，那就是：我们必须赢得这一周。这就是我们的口号。所以无论那一周有多少场比赛，它都会给你一个单一的焦点：你需要做什么
to win the week. We need to have a winning record every week. And that's how you get the little bite size motivation for a nine month journey that there are so many emotional roller coaster rides throughout the year. And I think everybody, you want those little bit of celebratory moments, right? Whether you know you're gonna hit us, hit some down,
才能赢得这一周。我们必须在每周都保持胜率。这就是你如何在长达九个月、赛季中充满各种情绪过山车般的漫长征程中，获得这种细碎的激励。而且我觉得每个人，你都想要那些小小的庆祝时刻，对吧？无论你知道自己将要遭遇低谷，
some tough parts of the season, some tough stretches, but all you go two in one and a three game week, and everybody's like, yeah, we did that. Like for Insingin' this one for a championship that might sound weird, but it's real because it keeps you in the fight. And that was the way he came in for this year. For somebody who doesn't watch sports, basketball, nothing, but they're constantly striving
经历赛季中一些艰难的赛段，但只要在一周的三场比赛里拿下两场，大家就会说：“太棒了，我们做到了。”对于一个志在夺冠的球队来说，这听起来可能有点奇怪，但它是真实的，因为它能让你留在战斗中。这就是他今年来到球队时所采用的方式。对于一个不看体育、不看篮球、什么都不看的人来说，但他们一直在努力
to be the best that they can be and be excellent as much as they can. And that they might struggle sometimes with the moment when it's time to go to hit the shot, land the plane. What would you tell without getting too woo-woo, but is there something that you can say to the listener for them to maybe focus on that might get them centered and focus so that they've
做到最好的自己，尽可能地追求卓越。有时他们可能会在关键时刻、在需要投进那一球或让飞机平稳着陆的紧要关头感到挣扎。你会对他们说些什么——别搞得太玄乎——有没有什么话你可以对听众说，让他们或许能集中注意力，找回中心和专注，从而拥有
got their best chance at being the best part of themselves. Like, do you, do you focus on anything that's kind of evergreen? Don't fuck up. I think that one was good. That's a great bumper sticker. We need to write. We need to write. Nike was going to do that one originally. Before just do it, they was taking it was going to be don't fuck up. Here's interesting because I guess I mean, like you say, you know, I sound too cliche with it, but it's literally like confidence is built off your preparation. And that's first and foremost. And if you can't let yourself in the mirror and say you did everything that you knew and within your control to put yourself in position to be prepared for whatever that moment is, then you're already behind the eight ball.
最大机会展现出最好的自己？比如，你会专注于某种永恒不变的东西吗？别搞砸了。我觉得这个挺不错的。这绝对是个绝佳的汽车贴纸标语。我们得把它写下来。我们得把它写下来。耐克原本打算用这个的。在“Just Do It”之前，他们原本打算用的标语就是“别搞砸了”。这里很有意思，因为我想——就像你说的，你知道的，我不想把话说得太陈词滥调，但事实确实如此：自信是建立在你的准备之上的。这是首要的。如果你不能看着镜子里的自己说，你已经尽了所有你知道的、并且在你控制范围内的事情，来让自己为那一刻做好准备，那你就已经处于劣势了。
But then at that point, for me, the biggest hurdle that I had to overcome was like the legit fear of failure. It was legit. Like sometimes wanting to hide from the backlash or the criticism or the negative energy that you'll get if you don't accomplish whatever you set it up to do.
但在那个时候对我而言，我必须克服的最大障碍是：对失败的真正恐惧。那是真实的。有时甚至想逃避那些如果你没有达成你所设定的目标时，随之而来的猛烈抨击、批评或负面能量。
And once you go through that and put yourself out there, you realize it's not all that bad because that's kind of what life is about, right? I'm gonna do woo woo for just one second because to that point, I always say the greatest safety net in anybody's life is the fact that you're loved, right? So if you know you are loved
一旦你经历了这一切，并真正把自己置于聚光灯下，你就会意识到其实并没有那么糟糕，因为这才是生活本来的样子，对吧？我只玄乎一秒钟就好——顺着这个话题，我总是说，任何人生活中最大的安全网，其实就是你被爱着这一事实，对吧？所以如果你知道你被爱着，
and you feel you're loved by your husband, your wife, your kids, your family, your friends, your teachers, your whoever, your coach, you are loved. So if you are loved, you can fail a million times and still have that love to fall back on. They'll be there to catch you. That's the challenge, too, they're probably, yeah.
并且你觉得你被你的丈夫、你的妻子、你的孩子、你的家人、你的朋友、你的老师、无论什么人、你的教练所爱着，你是被爱的。所以只要你被爱着，你就可以失败一百万次，依然拥有那份爱作为你的后盾。他们会在那里接住你。这也是个挑战，他们可能，是的。
Make sure you have that sort of... All the orphans. All the orphans just got the feeling's heard. I'm gonna go fucking dick. You never think about the orphans. You fucking dick. You fucking dick. You fucking dick.
确保你有那种……所有的孤儿。所有的孤儿刚刚都觉得被冒犯了。我真他妈是个混蛋。你从来没想过孤儿。你他妈真是个混蛋。你他妈真是个混蛋。你他妈真是个混蛋。
You fucking... You fucking... I think focusing on all jokes aside, I have, and I can say what, especially in the profession that we're in, Jason started younger and so, but he also knows what it's like. I mean, I failed so much that I can't, all I did was fail for years. I didn't make, listen, we're all nodding, we're all nodding. Yeah, I know, we all are nodding because it's true. And I continue to do it. And I failed from the time I moved to New York, I was 20, I didn all notting. Yeah, I know. We all are notting because it's true. And I continue to do it. And I failed from the time I moved to New York.
你他妈的……你他妈的……我觉得抛开所有玩笑不谈，我有过这样的经历，而且我可以这么说，尤其是在我们这个行业里，杰森入行更早，所以——但他也很清楚那是怎样的感受。我的意思是，我失败得太多了，数都数不过来，我好几年时间里除了失败什么都没经历过。我当时没取得——听着，我们都在点头，我们都在点头。对，我知道，我们都在点头，因为这是事实。而且我还在继续这样做。从我搬到纽约的时候起我就一直在失败，我当时20岁，我根本没——我们都在点头。对，我知道。我们都在点头，因为这是事实。而且我还在继续这样做。从我搬到纽约的时候起我就一直在失败。
I was 20. I didn't make it. I was so broke. And I just didn't. And I failed all the frickin' time. And then there's that turning point I was talking to my buddy Eli about it, that turning point where, you know, whatever, it's just plays. You start to get better at it.
我当时20岁。我没能成功。我穷困潦倒。我就是不行。我他妈的无时无刻不在失败。然后就有了那个转折点——我跟我死党埃利谈过这个——那个转折点，你知道的，无论如何，这就是戏剧。你开始在这方面变得越来越好。
You start to get better at it. You start to get better. And then you also, I think you develop a, I don't know, it's like an armor, like your skin gets thicker and you start just going like, you don't think about the failures. For me, my own thing is like, I kind of think about the stuff that's working,
你开始变得越来越好。你开始变好。然后你还会，我觉得你会培养出一种，我不知道，就像是一副铠甲，你的脸皮变厚了，然后你开始觉得，你不再去想那些失败了。对我来说，我自己的做法是，我会去想那些行得通的事情，
because I think as humans, we just naturally, we can, we can have 95% of our life is working great and some 5% shit is bothering us and we will think about that 5% and that's raising us right. And so I had to do, I had to do so much sort of spiritual calisthenics to get to the place where I'm like, just think about what's working and focus on that. And I think that I got better at it, but fuck it took a lot of feeling out there.
因为我觉得作为人类，我们总是很自然地——我们生活中95%的事情都进展得很顺利，却被那5%的烂事困扰，然后我们就会一直去想那5%的麻烦，这把我们折磨得够呛。所以为了达到现在的状态，我不得不做大量的精神体操，对自己说：“只去想那些进展顺利的事，然后专注于此。”我觉得我在这方面做得越来越好了，但妈的，这需要经历大量的失败才行。
And that comparison is the thief of joy thing, especially for us when you're looking around and you see people who are different on different timelines within their journey, right? Like, who knows what they've been through, what they've exposed, and has positioned them to that place. Or, you know, when you have those blinders on,
而且“比较是偷走快乐的小偷”这种说法，尤其是对我们而言，当你环顾四周，看到那些在人生旅程中处于不同时间线、各不相同的人时，对吧？比如，谁知道他们经历过什么，接触过什么，才把他们带到了那个位置。或者，你知道的，当你戴上眼罩专注于自己时——
so the, whatever, like the journey, like the things that you learn through that failure, obviously we all know are key as long as you can make them useful and make them resources for the next step and not to tell you from whatever you put in your set not to do, but that journey, when you look back and to your point, I love that. The 95 to 5% thing is a real,
所以，无论如何——比如这一路走来，通过失败所学到的东西，显然我们都知道这是关键所在，只要你能把它们变成有用的东西，化作你迈出下一步的资源，而不是让它们成为阻碍你实现目标的绊脚石。但当你回过头来看这段旅程，正如你所说，我太喜欢这个观点了。那95%与5%的比率是一个非常、非常真实的理论，
real, I'm putting that in perspective of everything that I've gone through because it's the shared goals that you have with those people around you, orphans aside that are extremely, I guess the most memorable parts of life. I'm not walking in looking at trophies, like my rings. It's nice to have them. Don't get me wrong. Nice to pull them out, but those represent the not much journey I was talking about with what Coach said. How many weeks did we win that year? And just the little bite sized things that make a difference in terms of your happiness and your peace of mind and the joy that you bring to it.
我把这一点运用到我经历过的一切中去，因为正是你与周围那些人（孤儿除外）共同拥有的目标，可以说是人生中最令人难忘的部分。我走进陈列室看着奖杯时并不会去想：哦，我的戒指。拥有它们当然很好。别误会我的意思。拿出来看看感觉很不错，但那些代表的正是教练所说的那场漫长征程。我们那一年赢了多少周？正是那些点点滴滴、微不足道的小事，在你的快乐、内心的平静以及你为之付出的喜悦方面带来了改变。
So for us, that's a big part of dumbing down the pressure that you're in on a daily basis. And Sean, touch on the love from family. And you've been, it's hard to miss if anybody's followed you through your career, how present your family is, with your parents, your kid, your wife, whatever. They seem to be omnipresent, that wife, whatever, they're always, if they seem to be army,
所以对我们来说，这是消解你日常所承受压力的很大一部分。肖恩，谈谈来自家庭的爱吧。如果你一路关注你的职业生涯，你很难忽视你的家庭对你有多么支持，无论是你的父母、你的孩子、你的妻子，还是其他人。他们似乎无处不在，你的妻子，无论谁，他们总是——如果他们看起来无所——
present, that seems to be obviously a key to success. And how awesome is it that you can share this with your parents? Obviously, seemingly a lot. Oh, for sure. And even, you know, family structures and things change and you start to, as it even us in the dough, that we get real deep with it. But like my parents got divorced a couple of years ago and it's like
无不在，这显然是成功的关键。你能和你的父母分享这一切，这是多么棒的一件事啊？很显然，这意义重大。哦，当然。甚至，你知道的，家庭结构和事情都在改变，你会开始——甚至像我们在道里，我们对这方面有了很深的感悟。但比如我的父母几年前离婚了，那种感觉就像是
the way that life kind of forces you to rethink and reimagine all your relationships and the growth that happens through that. It's a real blessing and through some tragedy and through some trauma, right? And even when you're in those moments, you kind of don't see it. But I think the maturity that comes, you know, through all those experiences you go through is the appreciation of who's pouring into your life on a daily basis, who's, you know, giving you a sense of confidence in who you are as a person and the value that you bring. And the more that you can put yourselves in those environments and my family has been a huge
生活以某种方式强迫你重新思考和重塑你所有的关系，并且在这个过程中伴随着成长。这真的是一种真正的祝福，虽然伴随着一些悲剧和创伤，对吧？甚至当你身处那些时刻时，你可能还看不透。但我觉得随着你经历的所有这些历练而带来的成熟，是对这样一件事的感激：每天究竟是谁在给你的生活注入正能量，谁在给你一种自信，让你知道自己是一个什么样的人以及你所带来的价值。你越是能让自己置身于那种环境之中——我的家人们一直以来都是巨大的
support and stars all across the board and that in that respect I've now in the charge of passing on to my family and my kids and that's that's the beauty of Life right there. Yeah It sounds like you know no pain no gain, you know This is a phrase that I just thought up the other day that I was using quite a bit. I'm gonna write that down in the screen. I'm gonna write that down in the screen. I want to know the injury thing. We are worst injury. No pain, no gain.
后盾，各方面都是如此，在这方面，我现在负有将这份爱传递给我的家人和孩子的责任，这才是生活的美妙之处。听起来就像是“没有付出就没有收获”，你知道的，这是一个我前几天刚想出来并经常挂在嘴边的词组。我要把它写在屏幕上。我要把它写在屏幕上。我想知道受伤的事。我们最严重的伤。没有付出就没有收获。
I had, I've had, what, four surgeries in my NBA career. No way. Yeah. I had two early, my career, I had two ankle reconstructions. No. That were pretty nasty. I had two early, my career had two ankle reconstructions that were pretty nasty. And then I was just four years ago, I broke my hand, a big seven footer decided
我有过，我在NBA生涯里做过大概四次手术。不会吧。真的。我职业生涯早期做过两次，做了两次脚踝重建手术。不是吧。那些伤相当严重。我职业生涯早期做过两次脚踝重建手术，相当严重。然后就在四年前，我骨折了一手，一个身高七英尺的大个子决定
he wanted to take a charge while I was in the air instead of, you know, meeting me at the rim and trying to block a shot. And I fell over top of him and he landed back on my hand. So I have two beautiful scars on my left hand. I broke a hand. I had a carpal tunnel syndrome relief surgery on it. I'm a tax feeling.
在我腾空而起时去制造进攻犯规，而不是在篮下迎着我试图封盖投篮。结果我从他身上翻了过去，他重重地压在了我的手上。所以我的左手上现在有两个漂亮的伤疤。我手骨折过。我在上面做过腕管综合征松解手术。我正在发短信。
Just came back from texting him from... Sean got carpal tunnel doing a musical. We're in the same boat. We're in the same boat. Yeah, same. Add it to the resume. 82 games a year. 300 years. Are your fans know that all the things that you go through to put yourself in the same boat. I'm in the same boat. Yeah. Same. Add it to the resume. 82 games a year.
刚刚还在发短信——肖恩是在演音乐剧时得了腕管综合征。我们俩是同病相连。我们俩是同病相连。对，一样。把这写进履历里吧。一年82场比赛。300个J。粉丝们都知道你为了让自己处于同病相连。我和你一样。对。一样。把这写进履历里。一年82场比赛。
300 J. Fans know that all the things that you go through to put yourself in a position. I sing those for the performance. He did, by the way, that every night he had the ice before and after because he had to play and do eight shows. It was pretty crazy. I was piano injuries. Yeah. That's real. We all go through it. We all go through it. We'll be right back. Smartless is brought to you in part by Helix. Okay.
300个J。粉丝们都知道你为了让自己处于那个位置所经历的所有事情。我为那些表演唱过这些。顺便说一句，他确实这么做了，他每天赛前赛后都要冰敷，因为他必须一边打球一边演八场演出。这简直太疯狂了。我这是钢琴手伤。对。这是真的。我们都经历过这些。我们都经历过这些。我们马上回来。Smartless节目由Helix部分赞助。好吧。
All the kids are on Helix mattresses and it's been an unbelievable success. And you know how I know? Because they all sleep really well. You know the deal if you've got kids if your kids aren't sleeping well It's an issue all the kids sleep amazing and it's been Since they got Helix matches. I don't know if I can draw a straight line to it But it's pretty if I were detective I'd be like the evidence is clear
所有的孩子们都在睡Helix床垫，这简直取得了难以置信的成功。你们知道我是怎么知道的吗？因为他们现在都睡得特别香。如果你有孩子的话，你肯定懂的——如果你的孩子们睡不好觉，那绝对是个大麻烦。所有孩子们现在都睡得惊人的好，自从他们换了Helix床垫之后就是这样。我不知道我能不能直接把这两者画上等号，但效果非常明显，如果我是个侦探，我就会觉得证据确凿。
Guess what? Oh, sorry, I was just waiting for you to guess. Okay, well, Helix, they've got an awesome Black Friday sale. So keep listening to hear the offer. But let me back up a little and tell you about the Helix lineup. They offer 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Luxe collection, the newly released Helix Elite collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers,
你猜怎么着？哦，抱歉，我刚刚只是在等你来猜。好吧，Helix，他们现在正举行盛大的黑色星期五大促。所以继续收听以了解具体优惠。但让我先退一步，向大家介绍一下Helix的产品线。他们提供20种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Luxe系列、新发布的Helix Elite系列、专为身材高大的人设计的床垫，
and even a mattress, like I said, made just for kids. So, how will you know which Helix mattress works best for you and your body? Take the Helix sleep quiz and find your perfect mattress in under two minutes. Have you got two minutes to change your life? And your personalized mattress is shipped straight to your door. Free of charge, Helix is offering 25% off all mattress orders and a free bedroom bundle for our listeners in honor of Black Friday.
甚至还有我刚才说的专门为儿童制造的床垫。那么，你怎么知道哪款Helix床垫最适合你和你的身体呢？去做一下Helix睡眠测试，在两分钟内找到你完美的床垫。你有两分钟时间来改变你的生活吗？而且你个性化定制的床垫会直接送到你家门口。作为对黑色星期五的致敬，Helix为我们的听众免费提供所有床垫订单85折优惠以及一个免费的卧室大礼包。
The bundle includes two free pillows, as well as a set of sheets and even a mattress protector. Go to helix.com slash smartless and use code Helix partner 25. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long with helix better sleep starts now. Smartless listener, this episode is brought to you in part by FanDuel.
这个大礼包包含两个免费枕头，一套床单，甚至还有一个床垫保护套。访问helix.com/smartless并使用优惠码Helix partner 25。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。选择Helix，从优质睡眠开始。Smartless的听众们，本集节目部分由FanDuel赞助。
Score early this NFL season with FanDuel America's number one sportsbook. Right now, new customers get $150 in bonus bets with any winning $5 money like bet. That's $150 if your team wins. And if you've been thinking about joining FanDuel, there's no better time to get in on the action. The app is so easy to use. There's a wide range of betting options, including spreads and player props,
在这个NFL赛季，用全美排名第一的体育博彩公司FanDuel赢在起跑线上。现在，新用户只需下注任意5美元的胜负盘，即可获得150美元的奖金投注。只要你的球队获胜，这150美元就归你了。如果你一直在考虑加入FanDuel，现在正是参与其中的最佳时机。这款应用非常容易使用。上面有各种各样的投注选项，包括让分盘和球员数据盘，
overunders and just more, right? So, you know, I've always betting how long it's gonna take Jason. I wish there was a way that I could bet on how long it's gonna take Jason to hit his next shot on the golf course. Because right now, right now we right now,
大小盘以及更多精彩玩法，对吧？所以，你知道的，我一直都在打赌杰森需要花多长时间。我真希望有什么方法能让我押注杰森在球场上打出下一杆需要花多长时间。因为现在，就在现在，
we're looking at about 90 seconds to almost two minutes. And if we could start, if we could start dishing out odds on that, we honestly, that would be a good business. It would be incredible. I think I could make a lot of money. Anyway, I wish it was the thing. It's not, but if somebody could figure it out,
我们看着大概得需要90秒到将近两分钟。如果我们能开始——如果我们能开始为这个开出赔率的话，老实说，这绝对是个好生意。那可太不可思议了。我觉得我能赚好多钱。总之，我希望这能成为现实。虽然现在还不行，但如果有人能想出办法来，
please let us know, or at least let Fandall know. So visit fandall.com slash smartless and kick off the NFL season, Fandall, official partner of the NFL, 21 plus exclusion supply, C-Show notes for full disclaimer. Hey smartless fans, have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show Add Free
请让我们知道，或者至少让FanDuel知道。所以请访问fandall.com/smartless并开启你的NFL赛季。FanDuel是NFL官方合作伙伴，21岁以上，受限制条件约束，完整免责声明请参阅节目说明。嘿，Smartless的粉丝们，你们听说过吗？你可以通过你的Prime会员资格，在Amazon Music上免广告、提前一周收听本节目的单集。
and one week early on Amazon Music with your prime membership? That's right, all your favorite smartless episodes can be heard Add Free anytime on Amazon Music, and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all, you can listen to your other favorite shows like, I don't know, Bad Dates and Just Jack and Will. Early and ad-free too. They also have favorites like the daily part in my take. And up first, Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcast so we know they definitely have something
没错，你所有最喜欢的Smartless单集都可以在Amazon Music上随时免广告收听，而且你总是能第一批听到我们的最新单集，这样你就可以在朋友面前吹嘘了。但这还远不止于此，你还可以提前收听其他你最喜欢的节目，比如，我不知道，比如《Bad Dates》和《Just Jack and Will》，同样可以提前且免广告收听。他们还有像《The Daily》、《SmartLess》、《My Take》以及《Up First》这样的热门节目。Amazon Music提供最多免广告的顶级播客，所以我们知道他们绝对有适合你的内容。
for you. And it's already included in your prime membership. To listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com-smartless. That's Amazon.com-smartless or download the Amazon Music app. It's just.com slash smartless or download the Amazon music app. It's just that easy. And now back to the show. Steph, can you speak a little bit to the extent the league allows you to criticize this
而且这已经包含在你的Prime会员资格中了。要立即收听，你只需要访问Amazon.com-smartless。网址是Amazon.com-smartless，或者下载Amazon Music应用。网址就是.com斜杠smartless，或者下载Amazon Music应用。就是这么简单。现在让我们回到节目中。斯蒂芬，你能稍微聊聊联盟在多大程度上允许你批评这个赛季中锦标赛吗？你有什么看法吗？
in turn of in season tournament? Do you have any any comments? So this is not because I get paid by the NBA. I absolutely love it. Yeah. I'm hearing it's almost unanimous that you guys are all digging this. I'm still what it is brand new and so it's like soccer. They do it in soccer.
所以这不是因为我拿了NBA的钱。我真的超级喜欢它。是的。我听说大家几乎是一致同意你们所有人对这个都挺带劲的。这毕竟是个全新的事物，所以就像足球一样。足球里也有这种赛制。
I love it. Right. We're playing the same. That's the biggest thing. The difference obviously. We're playing the same teams. It's all 30 of us just mixed up in different groups. Then we normally are in our divisions.
我太喜欢了。对啊。我们在打同样的。这才是最棒的地方。显然不同的是。我们在和同样的球队交手。我们全部30支球队被随机打散分到了不同的组里。不再是我们常规的分区。
But what they did with the entertainment value and like, we played last night, first of all. Explain it to Sean. Explain it to Sean. Okay, so Sean, there's 30 teams in the NBA. Yeah. And we're all already separated into six divisions, five teams in each division.
但他们在娱乐价值方面做得很棒，而且——我们昨晚刚打了比赛，首先。向肖恩解释一下。给肖恩解释一下。好的，肖恩，NBA一共有30支球队。对。我们已经分成了六个分区，每个分区五支球队。
Yeah, sure. So that's been the way it's been for 30 years now. What they did this year was they took each, they were the 30 teams and put you in six different groups within the Western Conversors, three groups in the Eastern Conversors, three groups. And they designated four regular season games within those groups.
对，没错。30年来一直都是这样的。他们今年做的是，把这30支球队打散，在西部联盟分成了三个组，东部联盟分成了三个组。他们在这些小组中指定了四场常规赛。
So we play these teams anyway, but they designated these specific groups to say, this counts towards the end season tournament grouping. And so we played Oklahoma City last night and we won. So we're 1-0 in our group. We'll play Oklahoma City again, but that game won't be designated as the end season tournament game.
所以我们本来就要和这些球队交手，但他们指定了这些特定的比赛，并宣布：这些比赛会计入赛季中锦标赛的小组积分。所以我们昨晚和俄克拉荷马城雷霆队交手并赢了。所以我们在小组赛里的战绩是1胜0负。我们还会再次对阵俄克拉荷马城，但那场比赛就不会被指定为赛季中锦标赛的比赛了。
So there's still playing the regular season and the game they played last night against Oklahoma that still counts in the whole regular season. They still counts to the standings and counts to also counts towards this in season. Oh, that's crazy.
所以这依然是常规赛的一部分，而且他们昨晚对阵俄克拉荷马的那场比赛依然会计入整个常规赛。它依然计入积分榜，同时也计入这个赛季中锦标赛的成绩。哦，太疯狂了。
Is it a way for them to sort of like keep the middle the season exciting for the viewers? Yeah, it's for the viewers. And it just brings a fresh energy to our first, you know, 20 games up basically up until Christmas when it is kind of working Vegas for the people. So that's where it builds up to.
这算是一种让他们保持赛季中期对观众来说依然精彩刺激的方法吗？对，这就是为了观众。它给我们的前20场比赛——基本上是一直到圣诞节期间——注入了一种全新的活力，最终大家会在拉斯维加斯争夺冠军。所以这就是赛事的终极走向。
So after you play those four games in your group, the best team, or the team with the best record in each group, which would be 16s. And then there's two wild car spots, one for the West, one for the East with the next best record or all the tie breakers they have. So you have eight teams that come out of the pool play and then you'll play a bracket. So it's three games and if you make it to the final four, then we go to Vegas and they play two games there. Do those games count for the regular season as well? So the final four game does. The championship game is essentially the 83rd game of the season, so that doesn't count
所以在你打完小组赛的四场比赛之后，成绩最好的球队，或者说每个小组中战绩最好的球队，也就是6支球队。然后还有两个外卡名额，西部一个，东部一个，由战绩第二好或者通过各种同分决胜规则决出来的球队获得。所以你会有8支球队从小组赛中晋级，然后打淘汰赛。所以一共是三场比赛，如果你打进四强，我们就会去拉斯维加斯，在那里打最后两场比赛。这些比赛也计入常规赛吗？四强赛是计入的。冠军赛本质上是赛季的第83场比赛，所以它不计入常规赛。
towards the regular season. But if you play in that game and you win the NBA, like the financial incentive is 500,000 for each player. And for the championship. So you have to have a degree in math as well. Math and travel and travel planning the justice. I believe that's unbelievable. When's the end of that tournament? The end the first week of December is the like championship week of the NC the NC's in tournaments. So I have the semifinals. Sorry, the quarter finals, semifinals and the championship game. I think it's like December 9th. Don't call that. But it's the first week of December. And so basically they have the cool part is they, they redesigned courts
但是如果你参加了那场比赛并且赢得了NBA冠军——奖金方面的激励是每位球员50万美元。为了总冠军奖金。所以你还得拿个数学学位才行。数学、旅行和旅行计划的调整，简直了。太难以置信了。这个锦标赛什么时候结束？12月的第一周就是赛季中锦标赛的总决赛周。所以有半决赛。抱歉，四分之一决赛、半决赛和冠军赛。我想大概是12月9号左右。别把话说太满。但总归是12月的第一周。所以最酷的部分是，他们为这个重新设计了球场。
for this. Oh, yeah. So if you were just having to be scrolling TV, it's like, you know, you used to watch the on Boise State football games, with that blue field. That blue field. They did that with ours. So they kind of, you know, circused out the courts to make it look and feel way different. Was the box was the bucks. Nick's last night.
哦，是的。所以如果你刚好在刷电视，那就好像——你知道的，你以前看博伊西州立大学的美式足球比赛时，那个蓝色的球场。那个蓝色的球场。他们对我们的球场也做了这种处理。所以他们把球场搞得花里胡哨的，让它的视觉和触觉完全不同。昨晚雄鹿对尼克斯的那场比赛是这样的吗？
Was that in. Oh, every game that was on. So I think it's every Tuesday and Friday are the in season tournament games. And so yeah, you'll see that you'll know you'll like what the hell is going on on the court right here. So it'll stop you. Okay. No, here's I like going to lie. I like to go in a live basketball games. I think it's fun. Okay. Well, we got the quote Listener, you can reach Sean at 310 that's a bubbers ticker if you have an extra take are you looking for a single or a sky? I want to go to
那是吗？哦，每一场转播的比赛都是这样。所以我想大概每周二和周五是赛季中锦标赛的比赛日。所以是的，你会看到，你会一眼看出：“球场上这到底是个什么鬼东西？”所以它会吸引你的目光。好吧，这里——说实话，我喜欢去现场看篮球比赛。我觉得挺有意思的。好吧，我们有——听众朋友们，如果你有什么多余的票或者想找个单人座位还是包厢，你可以拨打310联系肖恩——这算是个汽车贴纸标语了。你想去……
What do you like a box? What do you looking for a single or a guy you want to go to? Or do you want to, what do you like a box? What do you like? What kind of fan experience do you want, Sean? Hey, let me ask, I need to know this because I've often wondered this. Some of the guys who play, who you've known and played with over the year, a lot of them are extremely tall. And we're talking guys who are, and so they go through life as these incredible, they're not just sort of 6465. They're like 696107 feet.
你喜欢包厢吗？你想找个单人座位还是包厢？你想去……或者你想去……你喜欢什么样的包厢？你喜欢什么样的？肖恩，你想要什么样的球迷体验？嘿，让我问一下，我必须得搞清楚这一点，因为我经常对此感到好奇。一些打球的球员，就是那些你多年来认识并一起效力过的球员，他们中的很多人都极其高大。我们说的是那些——所以他们作为这些身材惊人的巨人经历着人生，他们可不仅仅是那种6英尺4英寸或6英尺5英寸的人。他们是6英尺9英寸、6英尺10英寸、7英尺高。
I imagine do they have to just live like freaks? I mean, do they have to have longer beds? What do they do with their cars? What are they with their clothes with their houses? Do they have to have special planes? They're planes. They're always under that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's a process.
我猜他们是不是必须像怪胎一样生活？我是说，他们是不是必须用加长的床？他们的汽车怎么办？他们的衣服怎么办？他们的房子怎么办？他们是不是得有专机？他们的飞机。他们总是得猫着腰。对，对，对。这很麻烦。
Like our whole road hotel's a lot of them complain about the feet hanging over the end. There's nothing you can really do about that. I know they probably can't just go to your standard malls and go shop off the racks. They gotta have all the special tailoring and stuff. And it seems like a headache of just having to go and extra step or two for stuff like that.
比如我们客场住的酒店，很多球员都抱怨脚会露在床尾外面。对此你其实没什么办法。我知道他们肯定不能随便去标准商场里买现成的衣服。他们必须去找人做所有特别的定制服装之类的。感觉光是为了这些事情要多走一两步路，就够让人头疼的了。
They're not eligible to drive certain cars, especially if they're in the market. Yeah, I just think about some high luxury type stuff where they actually got to think about legroom and all that. Many vans. So that's it. Yeah, straight up. And you see, like, Shaq is the one
他们不适合开某些车，特别是如果他们在寻找特定车型的话。对，我只是想到一些高端豪华车型，他们真的得考虑腿部空间之类的。面包车。所以就是这样。是的，没错。你看，就像奥尼尔是那个
who's had all his cars like custom made for him. Where they like put the seat really. I know Shaq a little bit over the years. He's such an awesome dude. He's a hilarious dude. And one time I was with my kids, I was in Los Angeles. And this dude pulls up in this, in this black car. And the passenger rolls down the window and goes, somebody wants to say hello.
把所有车都为他私人定制的人。他们把座位调得非常……我这些年对奥尼尔有一点了解。他真是个极品大帅哥。他是个搞笑天才。有一次我和我的孩子们在洛杉矶。这家伙开着一辆黑色的车停了下来。然后副驾驶摇下车窗说，有人想打个招呼。
And I was like, oh, okay. And I looked in and I had to keep looking back through the window and shack and move his seat was obviously custom. Like it was in the back seat, basically. We've seen, I think he did a, I think he did a, what's up, big man? He did a crib's video where he went to his bedroom here. Like this, I think it was a core vet if I'm not mistaken,
我就想，哦，好吧。我往里看了一眼，不得不透过车窗反复确认，奥尼尔移动了座位，那显然是定制的。就像它基本上在后座一样。我们看过，我觉得他做过，我觉得他做过，最近怎么样，大个子？他做过一个“明星豪宅”视频，他在那里的卧室里。像这样，如果我没记错的话，那好像是一辆科尔维特，
but it was like a, not a Cali King. It's probably like double the size of that. And he takes it to the extreme, but I know all these guys have to really kind of take into consideration. Speaking of tall players, we've got a brand new one this year, this rookie phenom Victor Wembenyama. Have you played with him yet? Played a preseason game against him. He's seven four and he plays like me. Yeah, right. Yes. He moves. I mean, how, how is it? First of all, let's not say plays like you yet. Let's give him a little bit of time.
但它不是加州大床。可能比那个大两倍。他把它做到了极致，但我知道所有这些家伙确实都得把这些考虑进去。说到高个子球员，我们今年来了一个全新的球员，这个新秀奇才维克托·文班亚马。你跟他交手过吗？跟他打过一场季前赛。他身高七尺四寸，而且打球风格像我。对，没错。是的。他的移动。我是说，感觉怎么样？首先，先别说打球像你。我们给他点时间。
I mean, guys, it's got a pretty good J on him. He is, but I mean, I'm talking about consistency over time. He is the, he's the markers. He's like, I do like these, these dribbling drills where you use two basketballs and it's usually like a guard thing is we have the skill set and the hand out. He can do that. He can there's a video of him. You can look it up. Victor Wimbaiyamba
我是说，伙计们，他有一手相当不错的跳投。他是，但我是说长期的稳定性。他是，他是标杆。他就像，我喜欢这些运球训练，你用两个篮球，这通常是后卫做的事情，因为我们有这个技能包和手感。他能做到。他可以，网上有一段关于他的视频。你可以查一下，维克托·文班亚马
two ball dribbling when I saw it. It's just those smooth and fluid is like what am I actually looking at right now Kevin Durant would would be the closest comparison as far as agility and size and shooting. Yeah. Yeah, but then you see a side by side picture of what 7, 4 versus 6, 10, 6, 11 looks like. And you know, that's this different ball. Are they playing him? I've only seen one game, I think. Do they play him at center? Or do they play him at forward?
双手运球，当我看到的时候。它就是那么平稳流畅，就像我眼前看到的到底是什么？如果从敏捷性、体型和投篮方面来看，凯文·杜兰特将是最接近的比较对象。对。是的，但随后你看到一张七尺四寸对比六尺十寸、六尺十一寸的并排照片。你知道，那是完全不同的球。他们让他打什么位置？我只看过一场比赛，我想是的。他们让他打中锋吗？还是让他打前锋？
Because his size, I mean, so skinny, like, wouldn't he get beat up as a center? Like, would you play him forward? Greg Pave I would not go step in on his His expertise, but I would say if he's a match or a problem No matter who what position you play him at, but they also put some some beef around him and play him like at the two three Yeah, the extended guard in small four position just to make it even more difficult to figure them out. So I saw him playing against Derand once. I saw him playing against Derand the other night and why I watched the highlights and it
因为他的身材，我是说，太瘦了，作为一个中锋他不会挨揍吗？比如你会让他打前锋吗？格雷格·波维……我不会去插手他的专业领域，但我要说的是，如果他是一个对位威胁或者难题，不管你让他打什么位置都一样，但他们也在他身边增加了一些壮汉，让他打二三号位，也就是外线后卫和小前锋的位置，只是为了让他们更难搞清楚。所以我看到他有一次对阵杜兰特。我前几天看到他对抗杜兰特，我看了精彩集锦，
was sick just watching all the different shots that he had, all the different things, the block shots, the moves that he had. I was like, it was, yeah, it's like you're like, what, like you said, what am I watching? I've never seen anything like that before. that he had, I was like, it was, yeah, it's like you're like, what, like you said, what am I watching? I've never seen anything like that before. Like, I like the Kevin Durant reference because he was, he's the most pure score at that, that height where he can literally do everything with a ball. But this guy is, they're any, are there any other players in the league right now that,
太疯狂了，看着他所有的各种投篮，各种技术，盖帽，还有他的动作。我就想，这真是，是的，就像你说的，我在看什么？我从来没见过这样的东西。他所有的技术，我就想，这真是，是的，就像你说的，我在看什么？我从来没见过这样的东西。我喜欢凯文·杜兰特的这个比方，因为他在那个身高上是绝对纯粹的得分手，他真的可以用球完成任何事情。但这家伙，联盟里还有没有其他球员，
that, that strike you as, as a kind of unique right now? Like, are you sensing in any sort of new styles of playing that are coming into the league at all that are exciting to you? The interesting thing is, they always said I ruined the game. And by that, obviously, just everybody wants to shoot threes
让你觉得现在挺独特的？就像你有没有感觉到任何进入联盟的新打风让你觉得兴奋？有趣的是，他们总是说我毁了比赛。说到这，很显然，就是每个人都想投三分，
and see how far deep they can shoot. I mean, you routinely put it, I mean, Sean, this guy shoots front, there's a three point line which they give you an extra point because beyond this line, you know, it's just too far away. So that's where they give you an extra point. He shoots from the four point line. I tell you, Sean, they played in a arena.
看看他们能投多远。我是说，你经常投……我是说，肖恩，这家伙投得超远，有个三分线，他们会给你额外的一分，因为在线外，你知道，距离太远了。所以他们会在那里给你额外的一分。他从四分线外投篮。我告诉你，肖恩，他们在一个体育馆里打球。
They played in a arena. Sean, it's a ball going in the hoop. Where? Is it like, prove it? I'll size it near my house. There's organs playing at most arenas too. You love the area. Yeah, and tank tops are all playing in tanks.
他们在一个体育馆里打球。肖恩，这是一个正在进框的球。在哪儿？是像“有图有真相”吗？我离家很近的地方。大多数体育馆里也都有管风琴在演奏。你喜欢这个。对，而且大家都在穿背心打球。
Organs. What do you, one day you look up there, I'm just like up there playing the show. And if you end up as an arena organist, what do you mean? And up. Wait, I want to know something. No, no, no, no, but before, yeah, style of play that you see coming into the league at all. It's just like positionless basketball where everybody can do everything.
管风琴。你怎么，有一天你抬头看，我只是在那里弹奏。如果你最后成了体育馆的管风琴师，你是什么意思？最后成那样。等等，我想知道一件事。不，不，不，不，但在那之前，是的，你看到进入联盟的打法风格。这就像无位置篮球，每个人都能做所有事情。
It's kind of cool because that's the influence of, you know, them seeing my style and the warrior style over the course of the last decade where you have guys who were good into the locker room now and I have a locker mate who sits to the right of me. Brandon Pajewski, who's just turned 21 or about to turn 21. And so he was in when we won our first championship in 2015, he was in the sixth grade. Oh boy. And so you kind of see the influence of our, he's watching this and now, okay, I'm gonna work on this. I'm gonna try to add that to my game now.
这挺酷的，因为那是你看到的，他们看到我的风格和勇士队的风格在过去十年中的影响，现在有些优秀的球员进入了更衣室，我有一个更衣室室友就坐在我右边。布兰丁·波杰姆斯基，他刚刚21岁或者快要21岁了。所以当我们2015年赢得第一个总冠军时，他还在上六年级。哦天哪。所以你可以看到我们的影响，他在看着这些，然后，好吧，我要练习这个。我试着把这个加入到我的比赛中。
So you just see that infused into the entire league where there's just so many guys that are pretty versatile to do pretty much everything. And you asked the question about what position did this Victor Wimba and I'm gonna play it. Everybody plays every position now. And it's kind of cool to kind of see the mix and the match and the rotations there. Cause there's no, there's no stiffs that just are out there just to set screens and do
所以你看到这种风格融入了整个联盟，有那么多的球员都非常全能，几乎能做所有事情。你问了关于这个维克托·文班亚马要打什么位置的问题。现在每个人都打所有位置。看到这种混搭和轮换真是挺酷的。因为没有那种纯粹上场只是为了做掩护却什么都不做的
nothing else. It's, you gotta be able to be pretty skilled at everything. Yeah. Sean, ask him what his pregame rituals are. Well, I want to know that. Actually, do you want to know that? And his favorite city to play in. And I do want to know that. Sean specials.
呆子。你必须在各方面都相当熟练。对。肖恩，问问他赛前的习惯是什么。好吧，我挺想知道的。实际上，你想知道吗？还有他最喜欢去打球的城市。我确实想知道这个。肖恩特辑。
And then I also want to know a deeper question, which is with all of your success and how phenomenal you are and the talent that you have been given and you're very young still, you're 35, you said. Mm-hmm. You're so young, you could probably do this for many, many more years. But do you ever think about when you're by yourself and think about gosh, with all of my injuries and all this stuff, like I want to set a clock myself
然后我还想问一个更深刻的问题，那就是伴随着你所有的成功，以及你是多么的杰出，你被赋予的天赋，而且你还很年轻，你刚刚说你35岁。嗯嗯。你这么年轻，你可能还能打很多很多年。但是当你独自一人的时候，你会不会想，天哪，带着我所有的伤病和这些乱七八糟的事，我想给自己设定一个闹钟，
before my body tells me the clock. Like before, I want to think about this on my terms. Like do I have five years left to have 12 years left? Like what is the span of somebody like you in the field that you're in? And you can hear that in Visaline, right stuff, right? Can you really hear it? Can you really hear it? Less is hard.
在我的身体告诉我闹钟响了之前。就像在那之前，我想按照我自己的意愿来考虑这个问题。比如我还剩五年还是十二年？像你这样的人在你的领域里的职业生涯长度是多少？你能在维斯林（Visaline）听到那个，对吧？真的能听到吗？真的能听到吗？做起来很难。
He's trying so hard. Making use of the time. I think that's a great question then, because I've started to think about that obviously a little bit more as of late, because you know, there's less years in front of you than there were behind you. And going out on your own terms is kind of the goal. For us, my problem is, I don't know how long I can extend it because I really feel like I'm playing the best basketball of my life now at 35.
他太努力了。充分利用时间。我觉得这是一个很好的问题，因为我最近显然开始更多地思考这个问题了，因为你知道，摆在眼前的年份比身后的年份要少了。按照你自己的意愿退役可以说是最终的目标。对我们来说，我的问题是，我不知道我能将它延长多久，因为我真的觉得我现在35岁时正在打出我一生中最棒的篮球。
When you mix in the experience and reps and wisdom and then know how even balance and on court off course though. But then to your question, I know I'm not going to do it forever. So I talked to Tom Brady about it, named drop. And I feel like he was just saying, you can think about that and you can prepare for what the downturn looks like, but you kind of take it in two year windows. So it's like, what am I doing now that's going to prepare me
当你把经验、出场次数、智慧，然后是场上场下的平衡和技术结合起来时。但说到你的问题，我知道我不会永远打下去。所以我跟汤姆·布雷迪聊过这个，顺便提个名。我觉得他当时说，你可以去想这个，你可以为下坡路做好准备，但你基本上是以两年为一个周期来考虑的。所以就像，我现在在做什么来为自己做准备，
for even just getting through next season? Yeah. And then you just wash or repeat that until you wake up one day and you realize, one, I talked about earlier, the joy of the game and making sure that's always there and being able to meet the moment of the competitive energy that you need to have. But then also, yeah, am I really spending eight hours every off day just to get ready
哪怕只是为了挺过下赛季？是的。然后你就不断重复这个过程，直到有一天你醒来，你意识到，第一，我刚才提到的，对比赛的乐趣，确保这种感觉一直都在，并且能够满足你需要具备的竞争能量的时刻。但同时，是的，我是不是真的把每一个休赛期的八个小时都花在为第二天做准备上？
for the next day? Right. Like there's got to be some of them. And I love that Tom Brady is a starly, Tom Brady is a starless, the, no, just kidding. You can always like say, yeah, yeah, no, I mean, I want to play. What's the, what's the sleep regime? How important is it? It's huge.
对。就像必须得有一些。我喜欢汤姆·布雷迪是个无星……汤姆·布雷迪是个无星级……不，开玩笑的。你总可以说，是的，是的，不，我是说，我想打球。睡眠规律是什么样的？有多重要？非常重要。
I was always a joke like once you're getting to later in your prime, I have so many different apps and devices to help me guys sleep. Noise machines. Noise machines, black out goggles, the whole deal. And so it's huge because like that sleep debt is real. It's the only way to really rejuvenate and recover and lie your mind.
我以前总开玩笑说，一旦你进入巅峰期的后期，我有很多不同的应用程序和设备来帮我睡觉。噪音机器。噪音机器，遮光眼镜，全套装备。所以这非常重要，因为这种睡眠债是真实的。这是真正让人恢复活力、恢复状态并让你的大脑……的唯一途径。
You miss home when you're on the road that much? I miss it all the time, but it's where I get the best sleep. And I can't, I'll admit it to y'all. I know this is going out to the world, but it's when I get, see the family. I really miss you guys, but I do look for the road trips. Yeah, because you have to sleep.
你在客场的时候会想家吗？我无时无刻不在想家，但那是我睡眠最好的地方。我得向你们承认。我知道这会传遍全世界，但那是我看到家人的时候。我真的很想念你们，但我确实很期待客场之旅。对，因为你得睡觉。
Yeah, because you can't better sleep. I know I have my day alone. I do the same thing. And I can't, and I do look for the road trips. Yeah, because you have better sleep. I know I have my day alone. I do the same thing. And I can't, and I feel guilty. I'm in Atlanta right now for a couple weeks. And I feel guilty because I'll send her my partner. She's like, oh, our three year old. Well, I woke up four times, and I'm like,
对，因为你能睡得更好。我知道我有我独自一人的日子。我也这么做。我不能，我确实很期待客场之旅。对，因为你能睡得更好。我知道我有我独自一人的日子。我也这么做。我不能，而且我感到内疚。我现在在亚特兰大待几个星期。我感到很内疚，因为我会发信息给我的伴侣。她说，哦，我们三岁的孩子。好吧，我醒了四次，然后我想，
yeah, and I'm like, do I tell her I had nine hours straight? Because she's so mad. Yeah. She's so happy. This is definitely, well, I want to let you go, because we're our unit an hour. We don't like to keep guests too long, but I want to give you a chance to talk about this incredible philanthropy that you have going as well as your company, unanimous media. I mean, any part of that, you wanna highlight, I mean, there's so much there between underrated golf
是啊，然后我想，我要告诉她我连续睡了九个小时吗？因为她会气死。是的。她会很高兴的。这绝对是，好吧，我想让你走了，因为我们已经聊了一个小时了。我们不喜欢留客人太久，但我想给你一个机会谈谈你正在进行的这项不可思议的慈善事业以及你的公司，一致媒体（Unanimous Media）。我是说，其中的任何部分，你想重点介绍一下的，在不足高尔夫（Underrated Golf）
and eat, learn, play, and I mean, I don't know how you have time to be so philanthropic and generous and diversified with your production company too. So, yeah. It's, I appreciate that. It's awesome to know the doors, the baths, the walls open and the lanes that, you know, I never thought I'd be able to play in and build and grow
和吃、学、玩（Eat, Learn, Play）之间有那么多内容，我是说，我不知道你哪来时间去做这么多的慈善、慷慨，而且你的制作公司还这么多元化。所以，是的。这，我很感激。很高兴知道那些门、那些通道、那些打开的墙壁以及我从未想过自己能够涉足、建立、成长并产生影响的领域。
and make impact. And so when you talk about foundation, me and my wife Aisha started a foundation that it's called Eat, Learn, Play. And we are the village for the next generation of young kids, especially in the open community that need the necessary and vital resources to achieve and unlock their full potential.
所以当你谈到基金会时，我和我的妻子阿莎（Aisha）创办了一个名为“吃、学、玩”的基金会。我们是下一代年轻孩子的村庄，特别是在奥克兰社区，他们需要必要和至关重要的资源来发挥和释放他们的全部潜力。
And so we've been doing that for a little over four years and have- It's $47 million. Yeah, as you've checked that way, I mean, it's incredible. That's a huge community that's come to support. Yeah. And our goal, we cover all operational expenses for the foundation so that every dollar that comes in is 100% is going directly back into the community and now working with the Oakland
所以我们已经做了四年多了，并且已经——有4700万美元。对，正如你查的那样，我的意思是，这太不可思议了。这是一个巨大的社区来提供支持。是的。我们的目标是，我们承担基金会所有的运营费用，这样进来的每一美元100%都直接回到社区中，现在正与奥克兰
Unified School District to hopefully infuse $50 plus million over the next four years into the school system. That's where kids go to eat, learn, and play every single day, and so we're trying to meet them where they are. So we're super excited about that. And even when you come to Inspire's Indexed Interation, you talk about unanimous media, which for us is a unbelievable avenue and venture to continue to elevate storytelling in the way that I can with in the themes of faith, family and sports and you know been on that journey for the last four
统一学区合作，希望在未来四年内向学校系统注入5000多万美元。那是孩子们每天去吃饭、学习和玩耍的地方，所以我们正努力在他们所在的地方满足他们的需求。所以我们对此超级兴奋。而且当你来到“启迪指数互动”（Inspires Indexed Interation）时，你谈到了“一致媒体”，对我们来说，这是一个令人难以置信的途径和风险投资，可以继续以信仰、家庭和体育为主题，用我力所能及的方式提升讲故事的能力，你知道，在过去四年里一直在那段旅程中，它参与了一些非常棒的项目，真的觉得拥有我所有的风险投资，我们之前谈到过一百年前，我觉得我可以谈论这个几个小时，但我们只是能够利用我拥有的所有平台，篮球赐予我的平台，为当篮球停止转动时的下一章生活做好准备。我喜欢这样。为你们两个提供了这么多的机会和通道。
years and it's been a part of some amazing projects and truly feel like with with all of the ventures that I have we talked about a hundred ago I feel like I could talk about that for hours, but we're just being able to leverage all the platform that I have that basketball has blessed me with to have something for the next chapter of life when the ball starts going. I love that. I'm giving so much access and opportunity
我跟你说，看在上帝的份上，我在竞选。请竞选总统吧。你很有钱。不，开玩笑的。我甚至不是在开玩笑。我知道，就是我，就像这个。我也这么想。你正是我们需要的那种人，老兄。
to both of you. I tell you what, for God's sake, I'm running. Please run for president. You're rich. Nah, I'm kidding. I'm not even kidding. I know, it's me, like this is. I was thinking the same thing. You're the kind of person that we need, man.
我向上帝发誓。至少，看看你能为奥克兰运动家队（Oakland A's）做些什么，把他们留在镇上。那是糟糕透了。你知道，我当然是在努力在湾区保留一些灵感，但我很感激这一点。而且事实上，篮球是，我的生活一直是其中的一部分，
I swear to God. At a minimum, see what you can do for the Oakland A's and keep them in town. That's the worst thing. You know, I was trying to keep some inspiration in the bay for sure, but I appreciate that. And just the fact that a basketball is, it's my life has been a part of
你知道利用我们刚才谈到的所有事情的能力，但是你知道，希望再多几个总冠军，然后，然后接下来会发生什么，我会为那时的冠军巡回赛做好准备，我告诉你，从现在开始我支持勇士队。是的，和你聊天太棒了。你真是个大好人。你这些年给那么多人带来了这么多的欢乐并娱乐了他们。然后把这些转化为持续的行动，你付出了很多时间。而且你显然得到了，你是很多事情的受益者。但能够把它拿过来做你现在正在做的事情，老兄，这超级让人印象深刻。真的，真的太酷了。
You know the ability to to leverage all things we just talked about but you know Hopefully a couple more championships and and then and then what comes next I'll be prepared for then the champions tour I tell you what I'm rooting for the Warriors from this point on Yeah, I'm so I'm so awesome to talk to you. You're such a cool dude. And the thing that you brought so many people, so much joy over the years and entertain them. And then to then take that and continue, you gave a lot of your time. And you obviously got, you were the beneficiary of a lot of things. But to be able to take it and do what you're doing now, man, it's super impressive. Really, really cool.
是的，真的太酷了。这让我想说，肖恩到底干了什么？零。零。他一直在吃他妈的白面包。白面包。白面包。
Yeah, really cool. And it makes me go like, what the fuck is Sean done? Zero. Zero. He's done a fucking is ignoring your offense. No, he's just eating fucking white bread. White bread. White bread.
他妈的？天哪。好吧，向你致敬。干得真棒。继续保持。你还有很多东西可以奉献，我们迫不及待地想看到它。我迫不及待地想下次亲自看你的高尔夫挥杆。我也得亲自看看那个过程。
The fuck? Jesus. Well, cheers to you. Really well done. Keep it going. You got plenty left to give and we can't wait to see it. And I can't wait to see your golf swing in person next time. I gotta see the process of the person too.
我会把它调整好的。我会去洛杉矶。我愿意跟我们一起玩，老兄。绝对的。好吧，非常感谢你做这些。我知道我们争取了一段时间。谢谢你抽出时间。绝对的。
I'll tighten it up. I'll come down to LA. I'm down to play with us, man. Absolutely. Well, thank you so much for doing this. I know we were trying for a while. Thanks for making the time. Absolutely.
我很感激你们。显然是超级粉丝，一直在听。所以我们争取了一段时间。谢谢你抽出时间。哦，绝对的。我很感激你们。显然是超级粉丝，一直在听。所以继续做你们正在做的事吧。好的，谢谢，霍利。祝你本赛季剩下的时间好运。谢谢你。好了，别挡道。保重。
I appreciate you guys. Obviously, big fans listen to it all the time. So we were trying for a while. Thanks for making the time. Oh, absolutely. I appreciate you guys. Obviously big fans listen to it all the time. So keep doing what you're doing. Okay, thanks, Holly. Good luck, rest of the season. Appreciate you. All right, stay out of the way. Take care.
再见，伙计。他太棒了。我真的很努力地去理解这些分区，然后是子分区。你知道吗，肖恩，我想，我甚至想，我实际上想，等我回家我给你展示。我画给你看。
Bye, buddy. He's amazing. I tried real hard to understand the divisions and then the subdivisions. You know what, Sean, I thought, and I thought, I actually thought, I am gonna show you when I come home. I'll draw it out for you.
我有点懂了，然后你就会说，哦，我其实对那个挺感兴趣的。对，对，是的，这非常有趣。他超级有趣且酷。对，没错。哦天哪，杰伊，真是个靠谱的家伙。对，你们是不是已经联系他好一阵子了？就像，对，你知道，他的，你能想象他的时间很难去，你知道，当
I sort of got it and then you go, oh, I actually would be really interested in that. Yeah, yeah, it is, it's very interesting. He is super interesting and cool. Right, yes. Oh my God, Jay, what a solid fellow. Yeah, have you been trying to get him for a while? Like, yeah, you know, he's, you imagine his heart to sort of, you know, when it
对他合适的时候，你知道，我们很灵活。但我的意思是，他当时在旅行。闭嘴。对。就像，他不是说过吗？他今晚有比赛。不，那边是七点。那边有一场最后的比赛什么的。
works for him, you know, we're flexible. But I mean, he was like traveling. Like, shut up. Yeah. Like, what didn't he say? He's playing tonight. No, it's seven o'clock over there. It's a last day game there or something.
昨晚。我忘了他在多伦多。是的。历史结束了。他最后去了那里。是的。他去了一所学校，在热带。但毫无疑问，他跟这么多事情联系在一起。
Last night. I forgot that he was that there's a Toronto. Yeah. History is dead. He ended up there. Yeah. And he went to school in a topical. But there's no, it's no wonder he is attached to so many things.
他似乎拥有这种个性。就像不是每一个体育明星，不是每一个演员，不是地球上的每一个人，你知道的，都有这种个性去处理这些。他看起来非常非常善良，非常真诚，非常好，但我敢跟你打赌1000美元，阿莎，他的妻子，是一个比他还要伟大的圣人。我敢打赌，很多事情都是她在推动的，她可能应该得到一个巨大、巨大、巨大的……我确信，但正如你所策划的，当然，
He seems to have got the personality. Like not every sports figure, not every actor, not everybody in the, you know, on the planet has the personality to do with. It seems very, very kind, very genuine, very nice, but I'll bet you $1,000 that Aisha, his wife, is a saint even larger than him. And I'll bet she's driving a lot of this stuff and she probably deserves a huge huge huge. I'm sure, but as you plot, of course,
正如你所知，做事情，以最高水平做他所做的事情，需要大量的能量。而且我确信有很多人在不同的方向拉扯他，因为他有他的球场表现，这是第一件事，对吧？那是主要的，那是他如何到达他现在这个位置的方式。
and as you know, doing stuff, doing what he does at the highest level, requires a lot of energy. And I'm sure got a lot of people pulling at him at different directions because he's got a delivery, he's got a delivery on the court, which is the first thing, right? That's the main, that's how he got to where he is.
然后所有这些其他的事情都是其中的一部分。有名人身份，主要的是，那是他如何到达他现在这个位置的方式。然后所有这些其他的事情都是其中的一部分。有名人身份，有基金会，有这个，还有那个。还有一个制作公司。就像这样。制作。这需要，每一件事都需要如此多的精力、时间和关注。想想看，就像你说的，杰伊，关于他打球的时候，他看起来是多么毫不费力地完成这一切。也许这掩盖了像他，
And then there's all this other stuff that's part of it. There's the celebrity and there's the main, that's how he got to where he is. And then there's all this other stuff that's part of it. There's the celebrity and there's the foundation and there's the this and there's that. And that's a production coming in. It's like thing. Production. That requires so, each one of those things requires so much energy and time and attention. And to think how, kind of like you said, J.B. about when he plays, how effortlessly he seems to do it. And maybe that betrays like he,
也许他，你知道，确实在管理上经历了一段艰难的时期，但他看起来非常平衡，正如他所说。是的，看起来非常令人印象深刻。是的。这真是令人难以置信地印象深刻。是的。他在最高水平上做的所有事情。是的，但整件事，就像那是一个，你知道，他的整个旅程，那是一个故事。
maybe he is, you know, it does have a tougher time managing, but it seems like so balanced as he said. Yeah, it seems very so impressive. Yeah. It's so unbelievably impressive. Yeah. All the stuff that he does at the highest level. Yeah, but that whole thing, like that was a, you know, his whole journey, that's a story.
我惊呆了。再见。
I was blown away. Bye. Smartness is 100% organic and artisantly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umgurf. Smartness. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Everybody's had them.
“机智”是由贝内特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbakow）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·乌姆格尔夫（Rob Ungerf）有机纯天然、手工精制而成的。“机智”。我们的下一集将在四周内发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客上的万得利Plus（Wondry Plus）或万得利（Wondry）应用程序提前收听且无广告。每个人都经历过这些。
Everybody can relate to them. And now, it's time to celebrate them. Bad dates is a wild comedy podcast hosted by me, Jermila Jamil. So each week, my favorite comedian celebrities and funny friends share their epic and true dating nightmares and misfires that they've encountered on the road to love, to shacking, or both. Get ready for some of the funniest, most shocking, and get somehow still deeply relatable stories you will never forget some of the tales that
每个人都能与它们产生共鸣。现在，是时候庆祝它们了。“糟糕的约会”（Bad Dates）是一个疯狂的喜剧播客，由我杰米拉·贾米尔（Jamilah Jamil）主持。因此，每周我最喜欢的喜剧演员名人和有趣的搞笑朋友都会分享他们在通往真爱、同居或兼而有之的道路上遇到的史诗般且真实的约会噩梦和失误。准备好迎接一些最搞笑、最令人震惊、却又不知何故依然能深深产生共鸣的故事吧，你这辈子都不会忘记你将要听到的一些故事。
you are going to hear as long as you live. My guests include the excellent Conan O'Brien, Nikki Glazer, Tignotaro, Bob the Drag Queen, and many more. Plus, you will also be hearing from listeners who share their own date in the past. From the team behind the hip-hop cast Smartless, bad dates will make you laugh a lot, cry a little, and cringe just the right amount. Because as we all know, the worst dates make the best stories. Follow bad dates wherever you get your podcasts.
我的嘉宾包括优秀的柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）、妮基·格拉泽（Nikki Glaser）、蒂格·诺塔罗（Tig Notaro）、变装皇后鲍勃（Bob the Drag Queen）等等。此外，你还将听到听众们分享他们过去自己的约会经历。来自嘻哈播客“机智”背后的团队，“糟糕的约会”会让你大笑不止，微哭一会儿，并且恰到好处地感到尴尬。因为众所周知，最糟糕的约会能造就最好的故事。在任何你获取播客的地方关注“糟糕的约会”。
You can listen early and add free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在亚马逊音乐或万得利应用程序上提前收听且无广告。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。